what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel um today we have
four special guests on the channel and
today we're gonna do a special episode
where we are going to bring in four
algebra beautiful young women and see
what top high value men think of them
today we have brought in um four guys
that are in the top one percent of
earners we have verified their income
and they're going to be giving feedback
to the women that come on the show and
deem them at the end of the show
wife or cat lady
um so let's introduce the guys of
everyone go around say um your name and
just a little intro about yourself I'm
starting with Dimitri hey guys my name
is Dimitri I am the chief executive
officer for
lgfgfashionhouse.lgfg.com that's the
company that makes the bespoke suits for
a lot of celebrities around the world
offices in 27 countries and we're always
hiring for Sharp young people into sales
to build their life and wealth I am 40
years old I'm actually married for now
over 10 years we have four children with
my beautiful wife and I thought it'd be
really cool for a panel like this uh to
have some perspective from a dude that
is married that does have children and
then kind of view it from that
perspective and see how I would view
these ladies we kind of talked about
this concept so this should be a lot of
fun yeah I mean we always talk about
what high value men want so I think it's
really interesting because what percent
of women have actually been in the room
with high value men that are not
entertainers rappers you know the the
typical like high value men that we see
on TV and women seem to go for yeah 99
of men that are that are that are making
a great living that are living a great
life they're not in the entertainment
business they're they're professionals
they're why they know they're educated
they're you know anesthesiologists
they're Radiologists they're running a
small business that they've built over
time and it's not a glamorous shiny
lifestyle it's really just a life of
consistency discipline and follow
through and integrity and that's the
kind of stuff we teach and recruit for
men in our company to build
um go ahead
hey uh rainbow over here uh also working
with Dimitri uh I'm executive Claudia
which means in short I dress up uh guys
who
um don't have time don't like to shop
and want to wear
um high-end expensive business clothing
and I'll be doing this seven years and
that has put me into one percent I would
say uh in in in the country where I live
in and
um uh yeah I've been in a relationship
for seven years not married yet but it's
it's coming on the way
for sure and um yeah interesting
experiment to see how things have
changed or or what is the dating World
these days and what what women are
looking for and and see if if they align
with what the one percenters are really
looking for so very excited and tell me
do you want your wife to work are you
looking for a working woman
um is that important to one percent men
job I think it varies a little bit I
don't really mind it if she wants to do
it my my current girlfriend is a
designer so it's kind of like a it and
she's very like a Hands-On Arts uh
paints and stuff like that so I think
this is something you know you wouldn't
do for a real job anyway right so it's
yeah something that she can do but it's
not something that you select for no no
okay go ahead hi guys name is
rattlesloff I'm uh also an executive
Claudia with lgfg I take care of the
Bulgarian market and the Italian market
I'm 27 years old currently single and
dating active
so I'm in the day-to-day of meeting
ladies and maybe you'll find love today
maybe I'll find love today who knows yes
we're open to it uh before that there
used to be a professional guitar player
played in a rock band through my teens
which was a lot of fun and then through
lgfg I've been able to not only provide
for myself but support my younger
brother and his business Endeavor in
which uh you know I'm an investor
and that's it excited to be here excited
to see the ladies and see what's uh out
there and what traits do you look for in
a wife
that's very easy for a wife she would
have to first of all be good looking and
in shape that's the first thing we look
at no sugar coating it second thing
would be for her to understand what it
is that I want meaning that you would
submit she would be a submissive woman
she would be able to take
the second
person role
and go off of that
um
and also
I would say I would look at her past
and I would hope there's not much past
because we're not gonna be serious
no only fans
no that's not him I
don't know if she did it for like a
month then it's fine
God so my name is Julian I'm also an
executive closer here in lgfg I work
with the guys I'm 30 years old I'm
single and also active dating these days
um well before lgfg I had my own
marketing agency I was working with a
bunch of guys around the world and I've
been in the IDF in the Israeli Army I
was a diver and these days I'm living in
Madrid I just moved to Madrid to
continue their my business and growing
there and selling to that the one
percent guys in Madrid
high-end closing and what are some
things that you look for
pretty much the same as like Rado set
and also
and let's say
peace
I mean I don't want I have a very
stressful
working day
I'm kind of meeting clients I'm
traveling around I'm moving I don't want
to come home and start like dealing with
the [__]
[Music]
well guys at just pearly things we look
for Solutions so
try to bring people together and find
um so guys we have four beautiful women
that are gonna come in
and hopefully you'll find love today
let's get started what questions do you
guys have so I have a question for you
uh sorry what's your name Nuria Nuria
what is is
okay what is your favorite thing about
your dad
favorite thing about my dad
that he um
multitasking does a lot yeah once what
does that mean it's quick thinking
um he's always like creative he's very
creative in the things he does he
um adapts adapts really well to the
situations that he's put on is he put
into a lot of compromising situations no
he's uh he's in the he's an artist back
in my country really known artist and
he's also a businessman and so he
creates opportunity towards he uses
music to get into business in a way so
that's kind of creative thing it's a
multitasking thing so is he still with
your mom no not not together anymore was
he in your life growing up sorry was he
in your life growing up yeah
yeah of course he was present where are
you from I'm from Portugal and Angola
okay wow yeah
um you guys have any questions
no how old are you oh my God you don't
ask a lady her age I just did wow
okay I'm 28. okay yeah
have you been in any relationship before
yeah I have can you describe your of
course your signal now but can you
describe your most successful
relationship how was it laughs
[Music]
I um there was a lot of communication I
think it's key to understanding each
other
patients as well was needed for us to
understand each other I think I was more
patient and more understanding
um sorry you said you were more patient
is that a relative term like you were
more patient you became more patient you
were more patient than him
I became more patient to to understand
because I feel like if two people don't
agree into certain things
um
there won't be
um how can I say a direction there's no
Direction so I had to be kind of that
person why'd you break up
because he didn't compromise
can you be more specific
um he
he will he was not ready to be the
person that um I wanted him to be in a
way because I mean more serious take
take to another to the next level so you
wanted to like get married or something
and he didn't more officialize the
relationship was it a relationship or a
situationship it was a relationship but
it turned into a situation because he
wanted to be more like the single
Bachelor did you have a job what do you
do for a job
oh my God
he um
he that he was a he was a producer yeah
was he sketchy like did he have any sort
of like sketchy stuff about him like any
sort of
he had a lot of trust issues
yeah trust issues yeah because of his uh
past relationship so it took him it was
taking him a while to
it took him a while like it took him a
while to
to kind of like
open be more open yeah how long ago did
that end
um two years ago when was the last time
you guys talked or texted
um that's around the same time yeah so
you're 28 when do you want to be married
start a family have kids
um
I feel like I I want to do that whenever
I am ready
I don't think I am in a position in my
life that I'm ready I just started like
I just I'm just part of like this new
corporate world so I um I'm getting
opportunities and I feel like to have a
child it's a big responsibility
especially
yeah so I I need to be careful the
partner that I choose yeah so what if
you got to stay home though would you
give that up because like obviously the
guys here you wouldn't have to work I
wouldn't even
um if if he compromised and he he would
not cheat and if he was loyal obviously
I um
there would be um there would be a
middle ground can I see what's a middle
ground what does that mean like because
the question was very clear it was a
binary question it was like would you
give up your job and be a stay-home wife
or Mom and you said there's a middle
ground what does that mean if she has
her needs Med which is important right
meaning that the guy takes care of right
so everything right like the guy's got a
mansion a couple of fast cars and and
access to the whole world like would you
just stay home and not work it's like no
I don't want you going to work I prefer
that like if I'm a man I want to feel
like a man I just want to obviously have
my wife in the workplace and you what
you said there's a compromise to me this
sounds like a dream like doesn't that
sound like a dream it is it really do
you feel fulfilled though like because
you're just home like what about your
needs as a woman what does it means as a
woman for example it's not just about
money and cars and big houses obviously
I have to take care of the kids but what
about I'm a human before I'm a woman
what does that mean like what like what
are you what are you what what would not
be met like we're just asking questions
about your opinion on this right like
what needs do you feel if that was the
only thing you had what needs would you
think would still need to be met as a
human or as a woman for example I'm a
creative I would if if that wouldn't
compromise if I could be creative
[Music]
what if I put a garden for you to be
creative and just you know
be creative grow on our own food and I
don't know make a playground outside for
the kids
you have a lot of options to be created
in the house so why not maybe can I can
I ask what do you think is the role of a
wife
what does a wife do like if you if you
land that guy that takes care of you and
he fulfills
all of your needs right then what is
your role what do you give back to that
guy to to keep the house in intact the
children the husband making sure that
you know you're I'm supposed to be your
piece
so whenever you come home you
I can you know I can take part of the
things that you might
need to feel in need when you're outside
but I have not been a wife yet so I I
can only say from what I see I I don't
have that experience would your husband
need to like help with the dishes and
help clean around the house as well
yeah you wanna you wanna you wanna share
the chores kind of thing is that share
yeah he could help if I'm if if I'm
tired or something he could definitely
help why not
even if he's paying for 100 everything
you still got to do the dishes what if
I'm pregnant and I'm tired I mean and I
mean my mom ran a marathon nine months
pregnant no sorry eight months 11. I I'm
not nine sorry yeah but not everybody
has the same strength so would you
expect your husband to change your
diapers
why not um
also the father
he's the father
he's divorce
I actually don't you don't believe in
divorce I if I married I won't if I
marry I won't get divorced that's why
that's my opinion sorry you had a
question
uh yeah uh assuming do you have
Instagram you're on Instagram at all
yeah okay so assuming your husband does
not want you on Instagram would you take
it down for him
okay
so we haven't really spoke about like
the things that we do
I um I'm an artist I make music and I
work
um for Dubai tourism as a business
consultant and I represent Angola
so that takes a lot of social media and
and and you know I have to be there
networking if my husband
before being my husband I'm pretty sure
he knows what I am about so we have that
discussion the question is about the
personal account not the business
account or so even hypothetically if
you're working you're working but if you
don't need to work if somebody
takes that responsibility away right
yeah would you take it down
if asked I don't know can I ask you a
question Dubai is a very wealthy city
right so representing Dubai tourism
frangola you're probably uh representing
to some pretty wealthy man right yeah
you're not working with wealthy man yeah
hey boys how do you feel about your wife
professionally networking with as a
profession professionally not working
with wealthy men it's a it's a serious
question
guys what do you think like do you want
your wives do you want your future wives
networking with wealthy men
professionally who will not be my wife
simple no reason being is because
I think
um What Men really look for in a wife is
somebody that raises their status up in
other people's eyes
and I don't think that would look really
good to other people
Maybe
have you been to college yeah okay you
graduate yeah what was your degree in
music business okay business
administration okay do you go clubbing
with friends I don't really like going
clubbing
what are your what do your guy friends
do Siri what do your guy friends do
um
they entrepreneurs they're in the music
business as well
um
yeah do you have more guy friends or
girlfriends
growing up I was more like a tom tom
girl I used to do like the car race not
car racing like um skateboards this kind
of stuff track because I was a sport
girl I did tracking and stuff like that
so I was very masculine but now growing
up I feel like there's a woman need to
be more
um they need to be more around feminine
energy so do you think do you think it's
like
fine like if you're if somebody's dating
to marry or you're you're dating to
marry them uh do you think it's normal
and totally healthy for you to have male
friends
if it's totally so do you think it's do
you think it's totally then
um it's totally fine for you if you're
dating to marry a man or if a man is
dating to marry you uh do you think it's
perfectly fine for you to have male
friends
uh I don't know how
I don't know how to feel about that
because um I'm pretty sure I wouldn't
feel comfortable my husband as well have
a lot of female friends so yeah
how many kids do you want
two two kids yeah because of me and my
brother so yeah what if your husband
wanted more would you have more yeah of
course okay yeah I would definitely
so then what do you look for in a guy
somebody that um
somebody that can understand that can
listen
that can be fun but also can be
um grounded because I am
I am I'm very in my own corner I don't
I don't really like going out I I'd
rather do like experiences I don't know
if that's the word experiences I'd
rather have like experiences than just
doing
I don't know just random stuff and so
the guy would have to be an open-minded
person to explore the world and stuff
like that yeah how would you feel about
the fact that with a guy that is in the
top one percent you would always come in
second place after his business career
and goals
what if I became in second place no you
would always be a second place priority
the first thing for a guy like that
would always be his dreams and goals
um
I don't think I would I would um
probably
be with him
so why should a guy like that pick you
I got like one two percent so like I'm
like what what percent of guys do you
think are millionaires
the one percent yeah yeah I know it's
about like it's like what one that's
actually about it's actually interesting
it's about ten percent of guys are
actually millionaires in Western World
people don't believe that because they
haven't yeah this is a statistic a lot
of people don't believe until they
really Google it get into it so the
average millionaire is not making a
million dollars a year oh yeah the
average millionaire average yeah the
average millionaire makes ten uh the
average millionaire makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year okay hundred
thousand dollars a year it's the average
millionaire uh so about ten percent of
men make 100K about one out of ten guys
which which is that's more believable
right right so if we know that one out
of ten guys is about six figures and we
know that uh the average millionaire
makes 100 000 a year then it makes sense
of the average millionaire is about 10
is about 10 of people right uh but the
average millionaire is not 28 years old
either right the average millionaire is
a bit older and they kind of built their
life and build their career
um but that's interesting so you
wouldn't you wouldn't be with a guy
where you came second to his career you
came second to his mission and his goal
you wouldn't you wouldn't you wouldn't
want to come second actually
um
if I had already found him that with
that passion because as I said I also
have a passion myself
um maybe I would try to understand
because you said that you bring peace in
right yeah peace so exactly so but it's
not very peaceful for a guy to have to
explain to his wife why he's late and
not home again because he's working
exactly yes makes sense yeah it makes
sense it does make sense so my wife had
to leave her job for me because she had
to move countries because I'm like hey I
got a business going it's over here and
I have to move to this new country and
she had to leave her entire life behind
while we were dating would you leave
your whole life behind that you're doing
right now for somebody that you're
dating if you're thinking one day you
want to be a wife does she have
everything that she needs what does that
mean do you give her everything like
once you're present once once we were
when we were dating I wasn't like I
wasn't like super bowling yet it was
just ambition it was a dream but she
gave up her dream for my dream so there
was no guarantee of a successful outcome
for her at all
so that's an interesting question for
you like you know if you see a guy
whatever doesn't mean that he's going to
be successful but he's trying and he's
hustling but you have to give up your
dream for him to be able to pursue his
dream how do you feel about that a lot
of women actually do that like when when
the with their partners and I didn't ask
about a lot of women I asked about you
calm down
um uh I'm sorry this is this is the
whole point of this right we're asking
questions to answer questions so this is
that a rude question to ask are you not
comfortable the direct question it's not
that I'm not
um I don't feel comfortable okay relax
if you're not comfortable with the
question you have to answer it but I'm
asking would you give up your dreams for
a man to pursue his dreams with no
guarantee of a successful outcome
if I believed in him okay
do you believe
um how do you believe that decisions
should be made in a marriage
what do you what do you mean so if
there's a big decision
um and he thinks one thing and you think
another how do you guys come to a
conclusion
that would have to be maybe like um you
have to go with the facts even if if
even if I don't like it I have to go
with effects okay so okay I'll give you
a scenario just [__] conceptualize he
wants a house he wants to buy this house
you don't like it you hate the house
how do you decide what you're doing
if I don't like the house I would give
him reasons
um
I would give him reasons not to buy the
house but then it would have to be like
pros and cons says he says no this is my
dream house there's nothing you can say
to convince me I want this house
well if he's paying for the house then
yeah we just have the house okay so you
could go with what he said yeah yeah
let's have the house I mean honestly if
if a woman is really attracted to a guy
and she really respects him I don't
think the the conversation is even gonna
be there I think what women really want
is a guy that they respect truly and
they see him as a competent leader yeah
and they follow and they're in the
support role and usually I found that if
a girl sees that and let's say Mishi
starts liking the same thing so I don't
think that's going to be a big
conversation if you're doing things
right as a guy yeah would your future
husband need to ask your father for
permission to marry you isn't it
tradition I'm asking what's your
tradition because everybody's different
right what's your what's your favorite
in Angola so there's a
in Angola for the the how do you say the
Grooms the groom yeah the groom family
so it has to come with gifts like uh the
the the how do you say the bride's
family makes a big list like we want
land we want this we want maybe the cars
we want money and all that so you have
to get this big things
um once you have that and if it's
approved then you get to get to marry so
just a follow-up question there guys
just want to ask you so the previous
relationship that you talked about that
was sort of your long relationship or
other relationships has every
relationship you've had been with a guy
that you'd feel proud to introduce to
your father I did actually yeah I did
and I have a really my father has made
sure like he makes
um sure that I feel comfortable to talk
to him about about this man and stuff
yeah how many kids does your father have
my father has
um let's just say four with me
no actually yeah four with me yeah what
does it mean with you sorry so I'm the
first and then he has three
um outside all with the same woman all
the same relationships yeah so you have
three siblings yeah four siblings
um from my dad's side okay yeah
and does your mom have other kids have
one okay okay so total there's five so
one half half sibling and three yeah
okay yeah
yeah that's it what's the goal of
marriage what do you think people marry
for a partnership
long-term Partnerships but what do you
what do you mean by that well now has
become a little bit of that because once
it's um it's signed a paper it's it's a
business but back then I think it was
more about the love and um you know to
have a companionship with somebody and
until what do you mean back then what
does that mean I think it was more
traditional one maybe
30 years ago or something like that so
you think marriage has actually evolved
from being loved to being more of a
partnership or do you think that maybe
yeah did you see the case of the I think
it was the footballer or something oh
yeah when he married right right then
the ex-wife she wanted to get right well
and he put and everything on his
mother's on his mother's name so because
she was expecting to get something
actually that's the opposite of what's
really happened in reality right like
marriage was set up fully as a
transaction right there was a buy and
selling situation where basically a man
would
um see his daughters as an opportunity
for future wealth because he would sell
them off to other wealthy men and that's
not saying that that's correct that's
just how that's how the institution of
marriage was built it was a fully
business transaction and in some
countries like we talked about India
previously like where the divorce rate
is only one percent it's still a pre
it's still an arranged marriage
situation where your family
um basically gives you a list of
candidates and then and then vets them
before you meet them and then arranges
that marriage for you right whereas you
know now in the west what's happened is
like India is a one percent divorce rate
in the west we have a 50 divorce rate
and that 50 divorce rate is actually
predicated by this notion
of a love marriage right and yet it's
interesting like divorce is still an
option in some of these other
traditional countries except that people
just aren't really getting divorced
which is which is kind of fascinating
like we think that like a love marriage
is the one that's gonna last but but
like statistically speaking this those
are the ones that just completely fail
and so and so in in regard to that you
know what I find interesting about
something you said is that you're 28
you're now in the corporate world but
you're not really you said I'm not
really sure I'm ready you know to start
like being thinking about being married
and all this kind of stuff so so when
you go on a date like some guy asks you
on a date right what is your intent
behind that date like what's the purpose
that you're seeking is it to have fun is
it to have a good time is just to see
what happens or is there something else
no it's obviously to be serious because
what am I wasting the time what is it
what does being serious mean I'm I'm not
alone okay for a long for a long-term
relationship is to you know to build
that trust with somebody and not just
spend the time how quickly do you know
if a guy's potential candidate for a
long-term relationship for you
um
actions of a man so how he acts
a on the first day he can you know be as
kind and show traits of a really good
guy or
um or I can date with him like for a
month and only in two months after he
can open be open to me and you know show
some some men are take time how long how
long are you willing to wait to vet a
man's character
if I do like him I for example I dated
somebody for over a year
and um
but we barely saw each other you know he
he was quite busy person so
um
I did
I did wait for him patiently but was
this a famous person he was okay yeah
athlete musician
um none of those when you so you dated
somebody famous and you barely saw them
because they were very busy to see you
yeah were you guys exclusive was he
exclusive to you outright you said I'm
exclusive to you or it was like Hey
we're kind of just seeing each other and
seeing what happens
we were pretty pretty exclusive looking
pretty exclusive that's not that's not
really that's a little muddy but were
you his girlfriend like every all his
friends knew who you were he introduced
you to his family he would not his
family but he would he introduced me to
his friends there was pictures of you on
his Instagram Etc sorry there was
pictures of you on his social media with
you if there were pictures of oh no no
no no no no no no okay
actually I have a question for that yeah
uh let's go with me okay let's take it
forward let's say you are married with a
guy you have a house he's taking care of
you and everything how would you react
and that the guy for example in the
things that we do we travel a lot and
sometimes for one week two weeks and
there are times that we are home maybe
a weekend or two it's okay in a month
how will you feel how will you react to
a relationship like that that you have a
man that needs to travel to take care of
the things that you have
um it's pretty much how how your wife
did so I would if if I could be follow
if I could follow you
um go with you and you know just to make
sure that you're okay and
um I would but if not I wouldn't mind
now what I mean is you staying home yeah
I wouldn't I he's traveling to different
countries doing the work and coming back
yeah I would understand yeah I have
another question this this is uh you
guys can ask all these lots of questions
here's a question you said you do
tourism Dubai yeah how did you end up
connecting with Dubai
uh so my friend she is a flight
attendant for like private jets and um
she met
um she met the CEO of the company that
I'm working for and they were needing
someone in Angola that represented
because Angola does not speak English so
and there was a gap and um
so yeah she introduced me she introduced
me to to my boss she said like okay so
I'm pretty sure I know exactly who your
boss is now that you mentioned the CCO
of a private jet company from Dubai uh
with that said do you think that you got
that position because they were looking
for a beautiful girl to fill that role
no they were looking not beautiful are
all the other people that represent
their countries are they kind of like
there's a lot of beautiful girls that
are doing this
they are interesting that's fine it's
not a bad thing I'm just asking right
okay okay so so that's that's really
fascinating so you're in a position
where uh it's predominantly or at least
you know at least
let's say a pretty large share of the
folks that are doing are filling that
role are just beautiful women and and
you know you're you're representing a
country but you're you're flying around
so with that said like
have you done a lot of traveling I do
traveling yeah you do travel a lot right
and somebody and who pays for that
travel I do okay when you say you do is
it from your corporate job that you have
or or where's that money coming from
yeah
for my job so what are some you're
asking is it that out of pocket or a
company money so actually I'm asking I'm
asking if like if you've um been dating
let's say a guy right and by dating I
mean like okay maybe you're seeing each
other once in a while but like you know
there's something going on is that guy
paying for you to like he's flying out
to Dubai for a couple days like to go on
a business trip etc etc okay what is
your question that's the question
is that your question yeah like do you
date guys that will like fly you out
somewhere to like on a trip I feel
uncomfortable no problem you don't have
to answer that I just that's a perfectly
fine not to answer it right but we're
trying to get to the course that's why
we're asking hard questions do you want
us to ask easy questions
it's not it's not about well it's about
virtually that of course that is it's
about virtue signaling versus truth
right because we can all say like
somebody is supposed to be dating dating
marriage right talking about my job
being you're insinuating not a lot about
not about your job about your personal
relationship you're asking guys to fly
out to Dubai I said I work for Dubai
right right no the purpose behind the
question is something else it's like you
know there's a lot of guys watching this
right now and those guys are maybe not
in a position right now to you know take
a girl out to France for a weekend or
take a girl out to you know London for a
weekend from wherever they are like
that's just a reality like most men
cannot afford that does that make sense
and so when most men are are thinking
about dating and think about dating for
a wife they know that they're competing
against whoever else you dated before so
if you dated like a famous guy who's
obviously known who's got a lot of money
and you've been in that relationship
you've experienced that excitement
you've experienced that life and it's
hard to go back to an average dude that
just like drives a bus you know what I
mean I actually have dated average I
yeah because I don't want to because I
feel like people are just so interested
in money and stuff so I think he's more
asking like what kind of Lifestyle
you're used to yeah so like if you're
used to Flying Like if you're used to
like your last boyfriend the famous guy
if he flew you out yeah you would expect
if you would expect a guy to do that he
actually didn't he actually didn't so
um I'm used to
fly myself out because I'm an artist as
well so I I have like if I have shows I
have the producers flying me out or
stuff like that so
it's job related
all right uh uh we're done here and
they're gonna do the next yeah yeah
thank you thank you thanks for answering
the hard questions I know it's a little
bit hard when you're being put on the
spot to answer like this shotgun shotgun
questions
um we can just go into the questions so
if you guys want to start Rado why don't
you start because you know oh could I
ask what are your names first yeah
Julian Julian and rather okay
can you introduce yourself let's start
like that okay my name is Alexa Cara I'm
22 years old I'm a closer I live by
myself
um I have three brothers
and yeah what else do you want are you a
sales closer yes
ah High ticket sales closer with three
brothers
yes this is the best start I think we're
you know listen all of us all of us here
made our money and make our money in
sales like everybody here that's where
the money is the Alfa Romeo he bought
you know the Mercedes that he bought the
whole thing the whole like he just moved
to Spain like all of us we all made our
money at algebg the Fashion Company
selling and closing on high-end high-end
suits to Millionaires and billionaires
around the world so that's definitely a
world we know about so we might test
your competency here a little bit okay I
mean feel free I didn't realize I was
coming to work
everything everything's work when you're
a hustler yeah the young one the oldest
one between your brother I actually
haven't met the youngest two they're
half Brothers but the oldest one is 31.
how's your relationship with your
brother uh I respect him a lot I think
that he actually is the one that told me
to come onto this podcast I originally
wasn't going to and he was like you're
going and I was like okay sorry and then
you and there and that's where you met
Rado
is this like some pre-arranged like
marriage situation where are you guys
well the first the first girl was
supposed to be for Revo but I don't
think they quit yeah though zero
questions I I uh have a question uh so
assuming you meet a guy and he's
everything you ever wanted what do you
I guess how would you convince him to
commit to you
um
firstly it would depend if you want
something serious or no a lot of people
might tick all the boxes but they're not
actually ready for commitment some
people are very work driven and if I can
align with their lifestyle and it comes
naturally then I'm open to it
um but I don't think
I don't think anyone should be
convincing this isn't sales this isn't
worked yeah I was actually gonna ask a
follow-up so do you want to be married
some someday of course yes okay so then
if you want to be married and you find
the guy that takes off all the boxes for
you
how would you convince him to marry you
how would you signal that you are wife
material
for the lack of a better term to say it
so it would depend on the gentleman
however I think
I would ask him what his morals are
if they're the same as mine and I feel
like we wouldn't cause any conflict and
I would be able to be as peace of mind
then I would just start doing little
things which I think will make his life
easier because
I know that once we are married I would
be
you know provided for felt secure and so
it's my job in a sense to just hold up a
household and to show him that I'm
capable of that
and you being in sales clearly you're
um enjoying making good money how much
money your your husband would have to
make
is that a requirement
I think that women look for
potential in men whereas men look at
what a woman is currently in her past I
do not think that there's a certain
requirement
however I would just like to be taken
care of at least to the same extent that
I can take care of myself can I ask you
a question um have you had a serious or
long-term relationship in the past yes
so my very first boyfriend I met him
when I was 16. yep I was with him for
four and a half years we lived together
for three and a half years and
thank you
career took him to Canada I was meant to
fly to Russia and so I just thought
for career purposes that's so that's
really interesting and I'm gonna have a
very specific follow-up question on that
so when I met my wife we both were
working in sales and I actually uh met
her but then I moved to Canada and that
way that's right and so and so the
decision my wife had to make is she had
to give up her entire career because
that's where my career took me and I had
to be I had to be based there
um for uh and so she actually moved and
gave up her career and I would have I
moved to Canada would you have done that
yes would you have done it for this guy
my opportunity
um was brought to me first okay and so I
was presented the offer
um of having essentially a scholarship
and my mother just said you cannot be an
ungrateful child and say no to an
opportunity like this when people around
the world would kill for this so your
mother had some uh some say into your
the decision for you to either continue
that relationship for the relationship's
sake or to do this which put you first
at that time no right so after living
together for three and a half years we
hadn't
um considered getting married or having
kids yet so maybe it was just the age I
was at is it fair to say uh that and by
the way I'm not uh there's no right or
wrong answer we're just testing you know
what how how you think what your world
view is right is it fair to say that at
that time you made a bet that your
future
could have been better than the future
he could have given you no okay I think
so he was my age as well and he had not
established for himself
um as much as he has now so I'm really
proud of him he's now property
developing Canada so he's doing really
well for him so he called you up and
said hey let's get back together I miss
you and I want to marry you what would
you how long would you think about
pastas in the past we've both changed as
people and our experiences have changed
us but another thing when we were
together although it was very happy we
had no autonomy so we didn't know what
it was like to be independent we
revolved we were trying to build
businesses together and I think that
that was
the wrong approach it was a
like a immature mindset to have to think
let me revolve my life around this one
person because if that doesn't succeed
people change as they grow up maybe at
27 28 I might not view him the same way
I will always have respect for him but
the love can fade and at that point if I
have nothing else to turn to no circle
of my own
then
I would have been you know in a
different position and I'd rather not
get myself into that position can I can
I add a little interesting clip here so
one of the things that I learned from
Jordan Peterson is um and I love it when
he says this he says that you can never
compliment the person who's higher
status than you and that's one of the
things that's really interesting when
you think about it so we were with Eddie
Hall and uh riches from your podcast we
were working out at the germanetti hall
I think he was dead lifting about 400
kilograms it was the craziest thing I've
ever seen right like this is the
strongest man in the world and I go and
this is on camera this is on our on our
LG of G Tech talk Channel our LG
Instagram Channel I go watch those guys
and Eddie does a 400 kilogram deadlift
and I go Eddie man I'm so proud of you
for doing that
and then Eddie gives me you know so so
you understand what was happening in
that Dynamic world's strongest man I'm
just a guy I can't do a third of what he
does and I'm like I'm so proud he's I
couldn't that was a troll it was a troll
kind of a thing obviously because you
can't compliment somebody that's higher
status you can't say to Eddie Hall I'm
proud of you know it's like I can't say
that to him so when you just said and by
the way uh this is kind of what we're
here to do is to learn it's like when
you said I'm really proud of my ex what
that tells me is that you fell out of
love with him I'm just telling you
that's what it means because you can't
be proud of somebody higher status than
you because if you perceive them to be
higher status than you somebody that you
have to act with yes and submit to you
wouldn't be able to say I'm really proud
of him because it would have positioned
you then uh to to to be above him in
status so so you felt like your future
probably could you probably made a bed
that you could have had a better future
that's the subconscious thing that we're
thinking you mentioned how I fell out of
love but yeah in reality I think being
in love and actually like falling in
love is very different I feel like it's
a big chemical reaction maybe because we
spend so much time together it was
hormonally induced in a sense
um and love really what is painted out
in the movies is just a bunch of
dependencies in my opinion emotional
physical Financial family getting
involved and I just think that if you're
a victim yes that's true a victim that's
that's the victim mentality of love
right women stay in the relationship
because they're dependent on their
husband husband stands a relationship
because he's depend on whatever
emotional or sexual needs he may not
able to get on flea market from the wife
or maybe there's kids involved now
you're sort of a hostage in that
situation right but if you're making a
conscious decision towards a
relationship right like if you're
choosing exactly the woman you want and
you get with a man that you really
really respect now I've been married for
10 years we got four kids this is where
men and women differ you men are logical
and women we don't think logically we
think with our emotions and so at the
time me supporting him career-wise
wanting him to build the Empire wanting
him to lead the household it didn't come
from a place of me being oppressed I
wanted to submit to him so that he could
then be the man that I would want
leading the household however yeah I
think he's just saying like it's when
you say she's she's right she's on point
that's actually what I was I was trying
to see what she was if what I was trying
the reason I asked the question I was
trying to see if what you're signaling
is truly what you believe
that's really interesting right because
women will signal the virtues that they
think they want men to hear but that as
you get as they start to explain that
question more and more we do this in job
interviews all the time we do this in
sales a lot you know you're in sales
right and do prospects lie to us in
sales they say call me back when they
don't want you to call you back they say
send me a proposal when they don't want
to propose it all they do is lie right
and so what you do is you ask a series
of questions because nobody's gonna tell
you that they're they're deceiving you
nobody's going to tell you they're lying
to you everybody just wants to look nice
on the outside and save face in business
and in life so dating and sales are like
the same thing right like we're just
trying to find out the truth and so what
you look you don't look at what they
tell you they do you look at the
indirect signals that signal their
actions yeah like the last guy we had on
here like I all I did is ask her if
she's ever had a guy fly her out to
Dubai on his money
you know hey have you ever and if I
asked you that you'd probably be like
have you ever right was that was that
was that hard for you to answer no that
last girl literally like she got
teary-eyed and got really really upset
and stormed off because what does it
mean if I say have you ever had a guy
just like fly out to Dubai on his money
and she got like really emotional upset
what does that mean because if you get
defensive by the question that means
you've probably done it of course of
course oh I just that's obviously I've
never thought about it like that
obviously because she said she said I
got a job in corporate like I got a job
in corporate I represent Dubai I'm like
okay how did you get the job oh my
girlfriend's a flight attendant or
private jets and she introduced me to
the CEO I'm like is everybody in that
company like a hot girl and she's like
well I'm like are Muslim she's like yeah
most of us are like hot girls I'm like
why do you think about the job I did not
put that together obviously yes
so what do you think actually happened
so her girlfriend is a private jet uh
it's a private jet Hostess which could
mean a number of things and everybody in
the company happens to be a hot girl
that gets flown into Dubai from time to
time we're not saying what's going on
there's no implication there's any
further whatever but as a man as a man
would you date a woman that you know is
flying around an airplane to buy back
and forth with her hot girlfriends for
her quote-unquote corporate job as an
artist dude I was telling you I'm not
gonna date him if they know my cologne
yes I'll talk about that that's amazing
yes so okay so I'm 27 right they date
anywhere from 27 up until I guess 22 23
would be what I've been mostly seeing
and I I wear a nice cologne I'm into
cologne I buy like nice things that are
kind of more expensive that not a lot of
people can get so then if I'm on a date
with a 22 year old girl and she knows my
cologne by name
she's like oh is this whatever clone
that's a red flag like immediately I'm
like how the hell this is like what 40
and 50 year old dudes were like how do
you know this stuff how and how do you
know it by name
uh makes sense yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's why maybe you didn't like catch
what dimi was saying but we do this
stuff all the time you just set up
situations to see the reaction and the
actual actions of the person because
what they say they want and what they
react to right are very different 99 of
the time well I don't want to go into it
too much out of respect for my
ex-partner but when the opportunity came
to me first for me to go abroad I did
ask him like what are we going to do are
we going to do long distance are you
going to fly out isn't there something
that he should have been doing because
it feels it it it sounds to me like
you're taking on the leadership role and
kind of trying to guide the relationship
and set up the boundaries and this is
supposed to be his job so it brings it
back to the point that maybe at some
point you realized that hey I can be
better off by myself than with this guy
in the future
because if you find yourself as a woman
doing the guy things which is putting
the direction
putting the boundaries of the
relationship and always trying to push
him to make decisions then obviously
you're not going to be attracted to him
and you're going to lose all the respect
I didn't lose respect but I definitely
wouldn't go back there she said she was
proud of him and that's the answer right
there remember you can never it's like
it's like
you can never you can imagine again you
just take that argumentative extreme you
meet Justin Bieber on the street right
just I'm Canadian so I'm thinking of
Justin Bieber so you're like hey Justin
man I'm really proud of what you've done
in your career
I mean with Children Of course like I
think 100 I don't know where he will be
in 10 years time and I'm sure he'll do
well for himself it's just currently
correct the man I remember is not what I
need right now because I have changed
over the course of a year and a half
completely fine
I don't want to disrespect him obviously
100 I never want to speak badly on
anyone and that's really interesting too
because you know one of the next
questions I'm going to forego it was a
question to test how you what you really
think about your ex and you're
intentionally guarding his reputation
you know one of the things you're going
to see this come up as well like
sometimes girls will [__] on their acts
like oh he was this and that he was
manipulative abusive toxic blah blah
blah and it's like okay that's a
narcissist I'm talking to yada yada yada
and I remember I remember very well when
I was like 24 25 and I was you know
still dating and I went on a date and
this girl asked me about my
ex-girlfriend that I had for a couple
years and I I was like yeah she's great
and my sister said she's like oh you
still love her I'm like no I don't love
her like I broke up with her how can I
still love her he's like she's like why
are you only saying positive things
about her because I'm like why would I
choose somebody that I felt and stay
with somebody that I felt negatively
about and even if I did why would I
signal that like that just shows that
I'm that I'm trying to win an argument
with a person that's just an entity of
space to this other person that I'm with
right now so I respect that for me
that's a huge green flag to say I'm
going to protect my ex's reputation
because that's your reputation too yes I
mean he would never speak badly with me
as far as I'm aware right and we never
hurt each other you know it was a mutual
decision
what do you like best about your dad
um that he
gave my mother the space to bring us up
properly
what does that mean it means he's not in
my life
um okay do you think that affected the
way that you
um perceive relationship review men at
all how did that impact you growing up
can you talk about that a little bit
and I see your little emotional so you
can avoid that question if you don't
want to answer because I can see it made
you a little emotional but I think
my biggest Idol is my mother
however my mother had to be a father and
a mother which I don't think is
the way I'd like my future family to be
I would want the man to take on the role
of making the decisions and even if
you know I want him to take my opinion
into consideration but let's just say he
goes with a different decision I have to
have full faith in this man that his
decision regardless of the fact that it
wasn't mine is the correct one for our
family and my mother had to make all
those decisions growing up and if it
wasn't for her yeah bro do you see
what's going on here this is really
fascinating especially for young guys
and girls listen if I can interject you
for a second most of the time when you
meet a girl that didn't have her father
in her life she absolutely despises men
because her mother spent the entire
relationship with the kids shedding on
her ex like being the dad saying what a
deadbeat he is blah blah and that woman
grows up she's like I'm an independent
strong [__] I can do blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and she gets all
this kind of she starts competing with a
man in the men's World right right so
it's like and a man's world is very
different because you know there's
always a there's a threat of violence
when we do business you know we're not
talking about we're escalating to
violence but there's a tension that
happens between two dudes that doesn't
happen between between two girls there's
no free
respects you know I have to utilize
different things I'm not going to come
across masculine and you're trying to
negotiate without my strength yes I
don't have the same strengths as a man I
have the strengths of a woman so I have
to play those to my advantage you know
big up to your mom for for not despite
the fact that obviously she had to raise
you alone which is like a it is it is
such a I mean statistically raising kids
alone increases the risk of everything
you don't want in life you know
including the outcome of your children's
relationships in the future but the fact
that you still want to respect the man
and the fact that you still show respect
to the man you were with tells me that
your mom was wise enough not to let her
relationship which unfortunately failed
she didn't let it fail you 100 that that
is some that is some big up to some moms
out there man that's cool when do you
want to be married by as soon as the
right person comes along but I'm in no
rush okay but if you met the right guy
tomorrow he says I want to have start
having kids immediately are you down
I would want to at least have paid off
my house so that I have something to
fall back on
um and then if I feel stable or he's
able to provide me that stability and
security what if he's cool to just pay
it off and take it off your head then
but he's just like yeah I don't worry
about it it's all taken care of you'll
never have to think about money as long
as I really get to know him and it's not
just a friend how long do you think that
process actually takes
getting to know somebody depending on
the person depends how much time he can
make available depends on average
what would you say I wouldn't know I've
only had one relationship and I lived
with him for three and a half years so I
don't want to base all of the potential
scenarios on that one man got it have
you been dating much after that no
actually I don't know how to carry
myself on a date this is my first like
dating are you making a million dollars
a year right now would you like to I
wish yes uh there's guys on this pan
over here we're all in sales lgbg
fashion house we're talking about in the
podcast yesterday lgfg you guys know
this right we make the suits for Jordan
Peterson we make the suits for Eddie
Hall make the suits for Lennox Lewis we
make the suits for well now uh Michael
Francesa is going to be in our lineup
Zach Wilds in our lineup and we're
talking about world-class celebrities in
the movie Skyscraper with the rock we
sell high-end clothing you remind me a
lot of Yana who runs on my uh runs our
company's office in Dubai okay Jana
actually started with us uh working in
Switzerland and then she had this idea
that she wanted to live in Australia she
worked in our office in Perth for a
couple years now then she moved to Dubai
to open her office they remind me a lot
of her
um and she's married
um so actually no she's not which is
really interesting but but she was in a
very very long-term relationship and I
think what happened was and you have to
ask her she moved to Paris for a guy and
what happened was she actually started
doing just a lot better than he was
because she was working with us and I
think that changed the Dynamics a little
bit you know what I mean it always
changes them it does unless the polarity
is flipped but yeah usually it's not but
but you know with my wife she was
working in our company while she I I
brought her in I was already with her
when I started the company so it wasn't
like I was dating a point nothing like
that so I was already with her when I
started the company and then she's like
I want to go in sales and do this and
she was my number one sales person after
two years in all of LGBT globally and I
still I still I said no no no like like
I want you know a traditional marriage
where
um I don't want you working because my
mom was a working mom and I didn't want
a working mom uh in my household you
know yes I agree I don't think yeah like
my mother she had to get nannies like to
look after us and so I feel like our
relationship would have been even
stronger if she had just been able to be
there for us that's what I want for my
kids
what did you learn from your mom's like
just because obviously she didn't pick
the right guy they knew each other from
the age of 12. really they knew each
other their whole childhood
um had kids really young 21 uh came to
London and I just think
you never really know a person so that
goes back to kind of the question you
asked it's do you have respect for the
individual because the person is going
to change your love for them is going to
change but the respect should never
change and not to speak badly on him but
he had very bad habits which I wouldn't
want in my partner there's a reason I
don't have those habits like drugs
alcohol that sort of like yeah alcohol
gambling I don't I don't do that so I
have a follow-up question because you
said that also before about your ex that
if you let's say 28 you will maybe some
kind will change and then you will seem
different or the relationship so let's
say you're married now you're 22 you say
right yes okay so you're married and by
the age of 30 it's almost a decade you
change you see life different do you
consider in a good relationship that you
have and you start seeing the your
perspective different do you consider
divorce as an option no once I get
married for me married I will only even
consider if I'm ready to have kids with
this person there's no other reason for
me to sign a document I can enjoy them
they can enjoy me we can have each other
in each other's lives but marriage is
kids and for the kids we make that
relationship work regardless of how it
is now yes I saw my parents go through a
divorce it was messy I don't want to
have to experience that and
I pray I don't you've thought a lot
about this huh this is like these these
questions were asking you're not you're
not ad-libbing you've been thinking and
projecting about your future and what
your future with your family might look
like like Law of Attraction you have to
know what you want Fair
I have a question uh what are the
qualities you admire most in men and I'm
talking good man I'm not talking like
just random
people just what are the qualities you
admire most
I admire
um
consistency
good communication
open-mindedness in a sense that he
should be able to
Carry business out with anyone from any
parts of any culture
um
to have really good like
family orientated values strong morals
to believe in God or at least believe in
a higher power
um to have good hygiene to
um that's very important that's kind of
important
um yeah I'm just spitballing here but I
think
yeah if you can pinpoint like two things
two things that you admire most in men
uh actually okay this might be
controversial loyalty I think is very
important because the same way we say
okay well high value man has the pick of
the bunch I think that if you are able
to be disciplined in your business in
your Fitness in your health in terms of
family and your time then why are you
getting distracted by other women if you
really had one woman at your side who
supported you and helped you build your
Empire then there shouldn't be a need
for distractions and that's a sign of a
weak man in my eyes or or a
non-submissive woman that he picked
yes yes so that's that's that's you know
one thing I I want to point out as well
we talked about language like when you
said earlier you know I'm really proud
of like so language indicates a lot of
things about people right so we're
reading signs one of the things that
when we get into this couch of Shame
here from time to time you get girls
that are giving life advice right and
then and then you ask but what have you
done in that field like the hero so you
should act in a marriage have you been
married no okay here's how I'm gonna
make a million dollars he made a million
no okay so they they come from this
place of this imaginary Universe where
everything seems to work only the way
they imagine it working and there's no
connection to the real world right I
told you that you remind me of Yana and
you said is she married and I was just
like damn she just got me
I was like that was that because she
understood that what what she needs to
ask is not is not the is not the um you
know the delusional sort of virtue
signal of what's good and bad she's like
well tell me about the result
tell me about the result you know it's
like it's like in sales too right guys
it's like somebody gives you sales
advice and you just look at the sales
report you see they're near the bottom
and you're like yeah I'm not going to
listen to your sales advice it's the
same even when you have like a older
chick that has been kind of living life
this covering yourself yeah but usually
22 year olds don't think like this no no
but that's what I was gonna say and when
you talk to a 29 year old and you're
like yeah I date younger women they're
like but they're dumb they know nothing
like they have no experience they have
experiences it's complete delusion and I
try and convince him I'm like you would
be surprised there are a lot of girls
that have their feet on the ground and
the fact that you made the wrong choices
is your problem and your problem only
they wouldn't admit it yeah when people
say I hate girls all the time say men
are trash and I say keep saying that to
yourself and you'll meet all of them
because they're really men out there
that if you were paying attention to the
things that you actually deserve and you
actually value yourself then you'd be
attracting those men and you wouldn't
have the time of day for anyone that
doesn't meet that standard so um when
are you and Rado getting married
or should I ask you what when are you
guys getting married
um I don't know how much we gotta like
do some Long Beach walks and hold hands
and talk about feelings and just do a
massage with the clothes on and then
we'll decide you know all right guys the
next one now yeah thank you thank you
for your time gentlemen enjoy thanks for
not rage quitting when he asked about
Dubai
okay uh feel free to start
so let's start by introducing yourself
hi guys my name is Shanae I'm 25 years
old and I'm from London
so what made you what made you want to
come today
um I'm very much interested like we was
just speaking briefly about you know day
in and it's just hard to find men that
are like that want to be men they don't
want to be the Men role these days they
want to be the women and I'm so tired of
that so I'm ready to find the man and if
he's wealthiest I got a question for you
what do you feel like you bring That's
Unique from other women
um I feel like I'm myself
wherever I go like I mix with a lot of
different who else can you be exactly
but you know I meet a lot of I meet a
lot of women that like show themselves
to be one person and then they go around
a different groups exactly I'm genuine
I'm very genuine I'm open-minded and I'm
a lover girl at heart okay you say you
want to find a real man uh who's who
growing up for you was a real who's
who's your male role model my male role
model would be no one
what about your dad
he's alright to a certain extent so then
can I can I can I ask then how do you
judge a man then if you cannot name one
that you really would admire okay so
yeah I don't really that's what I'm
saying so I think of myself as a free
spirit I don't really judge people I
judge you on how you treat me
so if you treat me in a that I feel and
feel comfortable with you and I can talk
to you have deep conversations about
silly things and really deep things and
we really get along and we click then
that works for me that's a very low
standard to find somebody to impregnate
you if you're going to be a wife so
let's let's raise the bar a little bit
well let's say like I like and we can
talk about stuff oh but you know but
he's a broker it's like okay but that's
not a high enough standard for a wife
because as a wife you're surrendering
potentially your entire future economic
and and Marketplace value by being
pregnant and risking being a single mom
that's probably not the goal I would
never do that to myself well okay so
again uh tell us tell us about like you
kind of kind of oh you know my daddy's
okay it's like did you have a good
relationship with him growing up at all
yes I did I had a great relationship
with my dad um I would say
he
he showed me that it's okay to be
yourself be yourself one thousand
percent you are perfect how you are
um don't let any guy
make you feel less than you are and if
he does then that's not the guy for you
so why isn't he or me a role model why
isn't your dad it's like that's my role
model for men
that's a very good question that I
cannot answer
can we try is that because I don't have
an answer for it because was there some
care I mean if you know you can stop it
you can stop at any point you can stop
at any point was there character issues
like you just you wouldn't miss yes that
was so there was like
um there's the good side and there's
always the bad side to people there's a
light and a dark in the inner day so I
feel like maybe the dark side wasn't
really for me
um I don't I I wasn't born in London I
was born in Sheffield so obviously he's
still in Sheffield he's not with my mum
so I feel like
the kind of Separation it made it feel
like I had to reach out more as a
daughter which I shouldn't have to do
I'm I am a daughter
um you're supposed to be my parent so I
just feel like I want a guy that just
like
goes extra mile that just like make sure
I'm okay like every now and then like I
don't need you to be on me like you know
like so hardcore but
just show a little bit of appreciation
that you care but yeah he's he's all
right he's all right he's not bad
so then what do you think you probably
have an idea of what guy you want can
you kind of talk about that a little bit
like what is the guy that you would
possibly consider committing to be like
and then I have a follow-up question to
that yeah sure so I like men that make
keep me in my feminine energy like
sometimes I feel like I meet men that
just make me
um very like masculine women did Keep Me
in My masculine I like I personally like
dogs
yeah you know how that sounds to a guy
though it sounds like me saying you know
what you need to make me like very
masculine you know I'm a little gay
every now and then but if you're the
right woman I'm not a freaking I'm gonna
blow your brains out I'm gonna take care
of you and by all means but that's weird
isn't it like would you date me if I was
a little gay but then if you're the
right woman I would be very masculine
like doesn't that sound weird to you
like if I'm like hey girl because if I'm
the one then I'm the one hey you're the
right woman I would date you rather than
so you believe okay so for example for
example like with masculine and feminine
energy like I'm like for a guy if I was
to date a guy and he would see me oh
where do you want to go
wait what do you want so you want to do
right take a little bit of a charge like
oh so I know this place this is a nice
place that I like to go to or I've heard
about it would you like to come with me
one of the feminine response to be like
wherever you want baby
like let the guy lead even if like I
don't think there's like the true like
the most feminine examples that I know
they're not masculine with certain men
they're just feminine regardless yeah
that's what I'm saying that I'm a bit
I'm a bit of a yeah I'm a bit of an
alien why did you split up with your ex
because uh like I said I just it just
wasn't it wasn't
for me it just wasn't the time did you
break it off probably
I think it was a mutual agreement like I
said we built a friend no we built a
friendship we started the conversation
to break it off yeah who started someone
I would I'll be honest I'll say him okay
so he's and I respect him as a man and I
would never want to force someone to be
with me who doesn't want to be with me
I'd rather talk it out and well so why
don't you just say he broke up with you
no I'm not ashamed like I'm not ashamed
you know what I mean and that's fine
because I'm not gonna wanna I would
rather you say something to me than us
be some in something that you're not
feeling the same way I'm feeling we need
to both be on the same page how long
were you guys together
two years was it exclusive from both
ends yes like you met his parents yes of
course no we were we was best friends
and why did he break up with you I just
feel like it was on his side he needed
to grow more and it just wasn't the
right time and for me
as I would say now I didn't see it then
but now I feel like it was the correct
decision how old is he he's a year older
than me he's 26 going to be 27 this year
and it was
how long it was ago two so we broke up
last year and is he still a DJ slash
actor yeah how can one man be two
nothings exactly period can I ask then
my follow-up question is sure okay so
say you meet this guy yeah right then he
has the money to provide for you he's
willing to do it he's willing to commit
he's willing to not cheat yeah
why do you think he would pick you like
what are some things that you would
bring into his life that would make him
pick you because imagine like that guy
is probably sought out by a lot of women
because most women want the same thing
right so then why would he pick you what
do you think
um I just think I'm really I'm really me
and me everywhere I go
if we meet and We Vibe like
you're you everywhere you go you guys
have so much in common this is crazy is
that why you're so quiet yeah damn dude
what's your star sign but anyway we
won't get into that but you know I just
think I'm me like I'm I'm really down to
earth like I love long conversations
like I'm I'm really a romantic but you
know like that guy that can provide for
you
he probably works a bunch of hours so
he's probably not coming home thinking
of having a long conversation with his
wife of course not every of course not
I'm not talking about everything stuff
here but the stuff you're listing just
sounds like stuff that every single girl
says to me it sounds super vegan means
nothing honestly think guy brings down
too many Romans I just yeah it's
annoying right yeah I just think for me
like what skills do you have that a wife
would have oh okay I mean what the
basics like cooking clean I mean I can
watch the kids how often do you watch
children do is that something you do
often um it's not something I do often
but I do have them I do have younger
siblings and younger family members so
so when's the last time you watched like
a baby like a baby baby yeah
gosh a while okay do you find babies
annoying no okay I love them like I'm
such a softy like I love baby's deep
right in my day when's the last time you
cooked for like a dinner party for a
dinner party oh I would say
like a good two months ago okay like I
cooked for my family what did you cook
it I made some salmon some roast
potatoes and some and a nice salad on
the on the side can I have a couple
questions I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go in go in hard I feel like
you've got a lot of hard because so
here's the hard question so like first
of all what you you have a job you do
something for work how do you make your
money right now so I'm a full-time model
right now full-time model on which
platform on all the social medias mainly
on Instagram okay mainly understood
um there's a few questions that's proud
from that but let me keep going so as a
full-time model on Instagram you
probably have some gentlemen that are
approaching you pretty frequently and
saying hey what's up
um have you dated anybody pretty wealthy
no do you travel a lot sometimes how
does it travel look how does the travel
look yeah like like where do you go and
how do you get there
uh I'd just be traveling I get on a
plane well I I was you I was I was when
I was 25 like I wasn't going on a plane
and traveling I didn't have the money
like well I I did but let's say 22 I
didn't have the money to go on a plane
just be traveling how do you be
traveling how does that work like who's
paying for the travel me so some of
course I'll be paying for my own child
is this like a modeling travel thing or
somebody's like well come do it so
sometimes I'll get a shoot I'll get a
book in abroad right and they sort that
all out right sometimes I'll do it
myself like I'm very last minute like
I'm like spontaneous my friends would be
like you want to go here is this this
you got it yeah I've got some places
we've gone in the last two years what
are some places you traveled so I've
been like Gran Canaria like mainly like
the European areas basically like Gran
Canaria I've been Portugal I literally
went there twice since January to now
um just places like that same same same
same modeling contract unfortunately
yeah same modeling agency in Portugal
was hiring you for something that wasn't
that was just a that was just for fun
it's like a girl trip yeah yeah so do
you have a more uh and your friends or
more girlfriends or boyfriends girls
are any of your female friends married
no so let's say you're in a marriage
think about that okay and
your husband is as rather explained here
he's working his office like it's not
home maybe he's doing some business
traveling during that time your friends
come to you and ask you to go for a spa
night
what will be your answer to that
the girl that's married or me or your
friends
and they wanted me to go for a spawner
with them yeah of course I'm going why
wouldn't I go
okay
um hey I got I got another follow-up
question that so sure
uh you know you make some money on
social media that's your thing but
where's the guy if you're dating he's
like you know he's pretty serious about
you and he's like look we can take this
relation to the next level but you got
to shut down your social media accounts
I have to shut down myself my my job
basically basically you have to turn off
your turn off he's like look I know
you're a model I know you're putting
yourself out there but you have to take
your Instagram down you have to take it
down like it's just not something yeah
these are so these are guys they can pay
for everything so so these if the if
these are guys that can pay for
everything
I would say that is perfectly fine
if you're helping me to build another
business that's outside of that social
media world that's perfectly fine why
would you be helping you build another
business
because you're taking me away from my
business no but I would retire like like
the guy oh you want to retire me right
like like you're like you're done we
don't need to talk you want to leave
right now no I've retired one woman and
that's enough
no yeah why not
um how have you dated since your last
relationship yes I've been on dates and
how how what's that I'm traumatized oh
you're traumatized gosh like I said
these men maybe it's just the guys I go
for I don't want to put their put you
all in a break I'm like do they approach
you on Instagram
where do you guys meet I'll be on set on
shoots and they'd be like trying to like
sneak it in like hey like what's your
Instagram can I look at it sure it's my
name s-h-a-n I say it's a hard spelling
y g n e and y g n e how
I found it okay
so yeah they'll just like DM me on Dubai
off of 3 000 followers Dubai this is
crazy no I said Europe babe no I'm
saying like you get to be you get to
work full so for example yes for example
for me I'm I'm very good at networking
so when I go to on set like I like to I
make sure that I network with production
or I make good um professional
relationships with people so that
they're able to just reach out to me do
you want to be a wife yes do you feel
like you present yourself like a wife
um yes
girl what is this
black and white and I'm just saying have
a look let me take a look let me yeah
you wouldn't say that that's the wife
you'd get my like what do you what do
you want in a mother like what would
what would a guy want in a mother
someone that's there for them that's
loving that's caring
okay but what else would you want in a
mother no I'm saying like when he when
he's picking a wife he wants a wife and
a mother right okay so one more one more
marketing hate that question yes I'm
saying when we're marketing or like when
you're trying to you know
what the [__] is this like do you think
it's good for a wife and a mother to
have her like her tits out on Instagram
I mean I feel like I feel like people
forget okay so no they don't the
internet I feel like no no no not forget
but like not forget the pictures I don't
mean things like that but for example
like there's a difference between the
old-fashioned way and the new fashion
now everyone's on Instagram and on
social media doing these kind of but you
still want the truth
a lot of a lot of people you still you
still were looking for a traditional
guide to take care of you yeah so you
can't have both you can't be modern with
I didn't say no to saying if he was to
retire me and saying yeah but why would
he want that when that's
I'm trying to help you so it's like no
I'm serious no I know I hate it like how
how are you gonna get that outcome so
right now like today right you're in a
room with guys that make millions of
dollars so this is an opportunity for
you yeah right because we don't walk
down the street and that doesn't that
doesn't happen no I know but it's like
when you have a chance like that yeah
and they look at your Instagram and see
your boobs out do you think that screams
like white I mean to be honest for me if
you want to judge me by that that's fine
you know what I mean I know I understand
that that's a part of what you see
because that's what I'm putting out
actually that's more than a part that's
that's your it's more it's always better
it's always better in person
but it's not
anything about who you are I know I know
exactly but that's what I'm showing yeah
basically is what you're saying that's
like the first
um
like thing that you would get from me is
my social media so I don't think guys
would assume when they see that what
they would assume
um
your personality I'm a hardware her
personality
[Laughter]
for me I I do not judge people by the
their social medias people portray one
thing on there and then they're
different in real life I don't really go
off that I like to go off how you you
just said it you just said it's better
in your life like rather than mitigating
that you just accentuated more like well
you've seen my tits they're even better
in real life like so yeah to get that
close babe I mean it's it's the problem
the problem it's fine that's cool I
understand like you're you're obviously
confident in yourself that's that's a
great thing but the signaling you know
it's like I don't know but you guys but
like would you feel comfortable let's
say considering taking a woman seriously
when I say seriously I don't mean like
taking her on a trip and like having
some fun I mean like would you consider
a woman to introduce your parents to to
get married to if 3 000 guys have liked
her boobs on Instagram I actually was
going to ask like uh she said that you
said that you were dating Leslie with
like really bad guys like douchebags and
stuff do you think that the guy like us
or someone outside that has a lot of
possibilities
we'll see that and we'll say Okay I want
to date her
um yeah because that's different they
need how they know social media social
media is more like the dating platform
these days do you think they will
consider when they're looking at those
pictures to date you for a long-term
relationship yes because I don't I feel
like there's more people out there that
put out more honest I'm very honest is
that okay yeah like if I see that I see
kind of expensive date easy sex that's
what I see yeah
off of that yeah and then
what they're trying to say is this is
what you're portraying and then maybe
this is why that's the treatment you're
getting so this is what I'm saying
people don't quote these days they don't
date
instead of you saying okay I see they
don't Court you I don't I really don't
have a problem getting courted like
women that don't like dress like this on
social media it's not hard to get
courted in 2023. and so I'm saying like
if you keep putting this stuff out there
like that's what you're gonna get no
it's very true and I understand that
sometimes you have to kiss a thousand
frogs to get you no you don't well you
don't you don't you actually don't I
can't stay with it that's just that's
just a reference I've heard but at the
same time like I said that's an excuse
for kissing frogs
and it's like they tell us that we can
do this stuff and it's going to turn out
okay but I feel like how old did you say
you are again I am 25 I'm 26. you said
that you have a siblings right yes are
you the oldest or yes I am okay so I can
tell you that I have younger sisters if
I would see something like that on my
sister's account immediately I'm going
there and when God like shut this
account off of course and everyone has
their different opinions about
everything okay there's a million
opinions on on a million things would
you want your daughter to do that on
Instagram
that what I'm doing if you're married
and you have a daughter and your
daughter starts posting I would want her
to do whatever she feels comfortable
doing I don't post anything good answer
do you think your husband will be okay
with that your husband would say hey I'm
okay with my daughter showing her
breasts on Instagram
my husband well if you get married like
a high value guy that says I have um yet
to be married to a high value man right
I have not been married so let's project
do you think a high value for me to say
what I would be like in that situation
when I haven't experienced that
situation of course I'm going to take
into consideration your thoughts on how
I live and how I perceive myself on
social media but at the same time I'm 1
000 gonna always be myself and if you do
not like that then you'll clean up the
man for me I'll put it let me put it
this way and this is I'm going to be
real serious here for a second like I
got two daughters right and if my
daughter
um is on Instagram and I see she posts a
picture where you can you know see a lot
more of her body than you should I'm
gonna find the guy that took that
picture break his freaking legs and I'm
not even like that's that's barely an
exaggeration that is just like not okay
I understand not even that then I can
see you're young and you're obviously
good looking and I can see that guys
would definitely tell you whatever to
sleep with you and I can also see that
you've probably not dated the truly High
value guy because you've never had
anybody set proper boundaries on you
that's the only reason you're able to
say I'm always going to be me and
truthful to myself and the thing is if
if you want a man that would take care
of you he's going to have boundaries
that you can't cross so you're not going
to be able to be you and authentic and
all that type of stuff of course and I
agree with that like I said because you
have all the leverage
experienced that yeah like I said I can
only give you my judgment on what I've
experienced so like I said if I've been
in a situation like that I would be able
to give you
like my boundaries on that and if I
would or things on I would and wouldn't
do do you think that men judge women on
their past
yes I feel like there's a big standard
on oh men have a thousand women they've
slept with yeah women no most men are
sexless most men are miserable and
sexless very few men actually have
access to that right
yeah I guess it's just you guys are
going over the you guys are going after
the same guys and then you don't really
see that I agree you don't see no I I I
I I one thousand percent agree with that
and I feel like regular guys do they
complain about all the other guys that
are paying money for the dates you said
that I just said that right exactly they
do and that's what I'm saying like I'm I
don't I don't put myself in a bracket in
a specific type I Vibe with if I Vibe
with you I Vibe with you and if I want
to feel like I want to get to know you
more than I will but do you think that
do you think that you really should take
some of these pictures down relax show
me one babe I want to see one okay just
the first one picture you can see both
you really no no it's actually sad to me
because you're probably I'd probably
what you top like 20 of beauty to be
honest like you're very very interactive
girl and I'm like you have the power to
be a housewife yes not every girl's born
that hot I know not every girl can do
that yes and you put this
yeah so so it's like it's like you have
this inherent value that could get you
this amazing outcome that not everybody
it's like this amazing opportunity
and you throw it away because it's like
you have you're in lingerie yes I I
definitely hear that like are you
twerking here what are you do you like
the attention that you get from those
pictures obviously um
what it does is it gives me more work
opportunities you know but then I always
this one I'm not always naked thank you
very much oh no your boobs are out there
too
but they're not even that big if they
were Katie Price boobs I would
understand that barely anything there
real questions find any that are okay
actually
I'm Gonna Keep it that's one keep it
real real question um like you know
you're you're do you consider first of
all do you consider yourself high value
woman
um
as a 25 year old woman
I would say
I see myself on the way to being there
okay
um have you ever been with anyone famous
no
have you
I'm married 10 years four kids oh nice I
I don't remember anything before that I
love that I love that for you
I aspire to be married for 10 plus years
just get off the page
no I'm seriously I just I'm trying to
okay how how you get there like this you
know what I mean um I feel like it comes
with social media like for me wanting to
be a model it comes with social media
and how no not about people a mother a
mother yeah how did we get to because
you know that 90 of your eggs are gone
by 30. are they yeah so if you if you
hit if you're lovely if you're single at
30 years old you're more likely to not
have a child than to have one so your
chance of having a kid drops below 50
okay so like you know we we know we're
on like a bit of a time crunch here as
women right yes because you have to
convince a guy they say you have to
first find the guy you like which is
like impossible because every woman's
picky I don't care who you are yeah yeah
so you got to find one you gotta find
one that likes you and then you also you
also have to convince him that you are
trustworthy enough that he can marry you
and have children with you exactly and
you you do and it's like how do we how
do we get there if this is I mean like I
said I'm still young I think in my brain
um not a lot of them and and I feel like
not for the men you want to be honest
for the men you want they like girls 22
23 like 25 26 and I'm 26 so like we're
old
actually when people say that they were
not old no okay we're not old in the
grand scheme of things like in life
We're Young right but to the men that we
want the men that want to be like be
fathers the men that want to be husbands
that want multiple kids we're not young
yes and that's what I'm saying any guy
that's for me I would hope that you
wouldn't see that and just Judge Me by
that of course that is the first thing
if you saw me on social media
do you judge guys based on what you see
like if a man is five foot four you're
like I don't care why would you laugh
interesting
character
I I give people yeah sure I always give
people the benefits if you ever date a
guy shorter than you nope
would you would you marry a guy shorter
than you
um I would I wouldn't rule it out it
depends how you treat me as opposed are
you picky yes okay so you don't want to
lie to you so you judgment all the time
and you roll them out all the time it's
okay I do too stop it like can we stop
no all the time people I've had I've had
for example I've shown a girl a girl
like one of my friends a guy and they
were like Shanae like what are you doing
like where do you see and I'm like but
it's not about it's not all just about
that okay just just because your friends
see him as ugly it doesn't mean he is
ugly I know so single women they keep us
single they do that's why I don't close
to them for advice I got a question do
you check a guy's Instagram before you
go on a date with him
I haven't before
okay but I've met sometimes I eat on
there no no but that's that's like
that's like the main standard of today
I have met what do you mean babe like I
don't go out and don't meet guys outside
come on babe so if you go to events or
somewhere and you're outside
and then they ask you to go on a date
I don't always have the Instagram that
wouldn't be the first thing can I have
your Instagram I want to see that
they're not a serial killer that they're
real like I know but this just goes back
to back in the days not there wasn't
social media back in the days sometimes
you just gotta go sometimes you just
have to go go on the day and see the
person I just would like some like this
seems a little dishonest like I think
you're capping a bit I think I think you
do you don't okay no social media you
know you know we should we should we
should try the social experiment go on a
guy's Instagram but his Instagram it's
like in the first picture he's like
sitting on the floor eating ramen
noodles in the next one he's stealing
ketchup packets from Wendy's because
he's like why spend money at the store
when I can just get free ketchup at
Wendy's you know on the next on the next
picture he's like I'm on my vacation and
he's like just watching TV in bed like
this is what I do for vacation ladies
and it's like and then you're like I
want to go on a date you see that he's
like but don't judge me based on what
I'm putting out in the world and
advertising myself as to everybody out
there yeah like there's got to be some
level of understanding
what I'm saying is I'm giving you what I
have
experience
experience on social media idea and I
haven't had their social medias and I've
still met them to go on a date after
it's not all on social media but I feel
like a big percentage of people meeting
people and going on dates is from social
media because that's like I mean that's
where you just like see people yeah yeah
like the whole point is you do judge man
yeah yeah it's all oh yeah of course as
you everybody does I feel like everyone
judges people a little bit but now
you're switching off of like you don't
want them to judge me and this is like I
think we don't understand that no but I
think as a person like meet me in person
but you can talk to a guy for five
minutes and know if you like him or not
you know you can't you're a woman I'm a
woman I know this and so it's like we're
asking them to not judge us but we judge
them all the time it's a bit of a double
standard
I hear that it's true well yeah so does
your what does your dad think of your
Instagram
[Applause]
yeah that's for them but uh he doesn't
mind it I mean he doesn't obviously some
pictures are not I don't want to see but
so um your dad's never said anything
like that's maybe a little much never
said anything
um no obviously like there's some
pictures that he might not like but
there's people there's people guys
there's people posting a Madness on
social media more than me I'm like soft
you're not soft I do this every day
so would you describe your dad as like
um as not overly masculine
no he is very masculine I would say okay
I'm just thinking like a masculine guy
it's usually protective of his daughters
I just wonder like why is he not
protective of you because you know as
his daughter like he shouldn't I hear
that yeah I'm also a grown woman I can
protect myself and I understand that as
from a further aspect yeah I get that
but at the same time I am a grown woman
I can look after myself like
no no no no
Point like we say like we can protect
ourselves no I know but you know what I
mean like yeah but dude let's be for
real of course yeah of course but
yeah what can I do here I can give it
all lacking no not a question more of an
observation I think if we put the
perfect guy right here in front of you
would not be able to tell he's a good
guy because I don't think would you be
able to tell I don't think if you put
the perfect guy right here in front of
you right now I don't think you'll be
able to recognize the characteristics
that he has that make him the perfect
guy would you be able to recognize the
same if I put a woman here in front of
you that was perfect most most likely
would you would you judge that from
experience
or just because you just know you was
born with it you just know
no one's born with it
experience it has to be experienced
exactly so that's what I'm saying for my
everything
it sounds to me like you haven't had a
strong guy in your life ever not your
dad not your grandpa nobody so that's
what Pearl was going at with this yeah
Instagram and asking you why is your dad
not taking care of of you obviously so
following up of the question that asked
before if you like that tension that you
get from the Instagram
that kind that that tension that you
will get from this kind of Instagram are
those guys that you are dating today yes
so you will never be able to experience
a high valuable guy treating yourself
like that because all the guys that will
treat you will be like that okay based
on that Instagram that's fine that's
your opinion
that's the truth you know guys one thing
one thing too like there's a we've had
like three very different interviews and
one thing for this one like
I don't know maybe there's no nice way
to express I just tell you the truth how
my feelings like I just feel a little
bit sad because like
um well I'll tell you why because you're
well spoken yeah thank you um because
you're probably in the top let's say 10
even for beauty that you see in this
country
um and there'd be a lot of dudes that
like if you had
at least signaled like more traditional
submissive feminine values you would
probably attract like a really really
different kind of guy and it wouldn't
take you long yeah but the problem is
you're you know at 30 90 of your eggs
are gone by 34 if you're single and
childless the percent the chance of you
having kids is I think now statistically
Zero by 34.
the unhappiest the unhappiest
demographic that we have right now in
the western world are single women age
40 and we see that because the
anti-depressants that are being
prescribed are now significantly more
for women than for men so there's an
epidemic happening there for the first
time ever this year in 2023 binge
drinking for women has exceeded binge
drinking for men so we're seeing a lot
of depression in women because we were
sold women were sold this dream that
you're going to be a bad [__] you're
going to be a boss babe blah blah blah
blah and you're out there you know and
you're like well I'm smart and I look
nice so I can be a bad [__] and I can
be a boss babe but the problem is you
know the guys that I take but the guys
that are taking you on dates you
wouldn't marry them forget them marrying
you you wouldn't marry them so but but
here's the statistic and I just I know
this I'm not going to change your life
here I'm just going to give you some
numbers 90 sorry 85 percent of
millionaires are married 85 millionaire
men have the lowest divorce rates out of
any other class of men so the wealthier
man is the less likely he is to get
divorced yes 85 percent of billionaires
are married so it's not like there's no
good successful loyal guys out there
there's an entire class of men yeah that
are successful and married and staying
loyal to their wives and raising Empires
and families and they're not choosing to
date you and and and the only reason
that's happening is because you have
this perception that
um I can do this stuff on Instagram and
have no consequences but there are
consequences no no I do believe there
are consequences like I do know that
there's some men like forget yourselves
like that no like you're like a guy that
was born 610 and super athletic I did
you I did tell you like it might be me
that's the man
but
but that's that's very self-perceptive
and that's incredible but but man but
that's but you want to get married like
guys do you want to marry a girl that
you compete with on male criteria
we don't want that right like we just
don't know
I definitely understand that but like I
said like so I'm thinking like you might
as well have just been born ugly yeah
you know you know because it's like
that's the house
you know but you know at the same time
I'm happy with who I am inside and for
me that's odama is and I'm gonna grow
with every experience that I get well I
really I really hope we can clean up the
Instagram for next time you're here
please can we just take yeah I will I'm
actually gonna try I'll try I'll do it
as an experiment okay I will see the
different clientele that I get this one
needs to go
um
I really wasn't expecting to see boobs
today that was like oh can you see that
uh well in the Instagram yeah yeah but
that's what I'm saying but if you didn't
meet me
my Instagram I'd want to see it of
course men do that no no we do that we
do but like of course like would you are
you surprised like that men vet women no
no no no like we have Tibet I'm not
surprised at all you know one of the
issues that um that happens too is like
young women they often don't vet their
men hard enough and it is a woman's role
in society to vet the men because the
thing is like women hold all the keys to
reproduction so it's up to women to keep
our societies uh in terms sorry men
protect our societies but women protect
our next Generation because they're the
ones that we produce so it's like and
I'm happy you know that of course but if
like if you're a woman and you don't vet
a man we see that a lot some girl
yesterday on the couch here was like I
just date gangsters and it's like oh
it's like that's what are you
reproducing for well and a lot of times
people like think my message is that
women have too high of standards and I
don't even necessarily think like high
standards are a bad thing I think women
we should have high standards but we
can't criticize the man for being broke
and Dusty like when we have Instagrams
like this you know like I think as women
like we just need to improve so I really
hope I really please take some of these
down
uh the next one thank you oh down this
one isn't so bad this one isn't horrible
not bad
okay do you wanna um do you want to
introduce yourself
I'm Shayna I'm from east London uh what
do you do I'm a fight if you're a
stylist okay how old are you 28 any kids
no kids okay
um so the guys are gonna ask you some
questions if that's all right yeah all
right we had a Shanae and now we have a
Shayna
it's funny yeah
yeah let's start so tell me uh like
we're gonna ask you some questions
obviously about yourself and like
nothing crazy but like who uh what's the
qualities that you admire the most about
your father
nothing why is that because he's not my
life
okay so there's nothing I can say about
him do you have a do you have um like a
consistent male role model in your life
that you look up to
no I've had some probably before maybe
people I can look up to but I'd usually
go to people that inspire me but not
consistently
do you have brothers yeah okay how many
siblings I have one brother and two
fifth of okay um when do you want to be
married by
hmm
I'm 28 for like maybe when I was younger
I would be thinking about now but
I'm not really sure to be honest because
do you want kids do I want kids
I haven't thought about it but maybe
eventually if I find the right person
then yeah
do you want the husband
eventually maybe but
I'm kind of leading with life because
I've gone past the age where I would be
probably having kids
how many relationships have you been in
free
were they all long
not really probably like one year
probably under a year and over a year a
year and a half in a year and so the
last relationship you had why'd you guys
break up who broke it off and why
um I broke it off because
it was toxic what does that mean toxic
in a sense like it wasn't further me it
was actually kind of destroy me how come
the kids
controlling
in a lot of bad ways
so he wanted you to like uh not do
certain things that you wanted to do
kind of thing like he was control trying
to control your behavior maybe toxic and
more abusified
okay and abusive like physically like
mentally emotionally physically mentally
emotionally psychologically
so physically what would happen he would
hit you
off the few months yeah
um psychologically
um
psychologically kind of just like say
things that I didn't really agree with
maybe but yeah so how did like the hit
happen like what would you guys be
fighting or like what would lead up to
it it would be like I'm trying to leave
and I'll take my bags and then
the hit would happen and then they would
convince me or he would convince me that
it never happened okay so you'd be like
walking out the door and then he'd like
what he punched you in the face he
dragged me back take me off the street
oh he he dragged you back into the
apartment yeah okay but he so then it
didn't sound like he hit you
um so that was like just a leading thing
oh okay like eventually it got to that
okay was that your first relationship
that was
um that had some of these toxic things
or was the relation before that like did
you feel that was toxic also not first
my first relationship that was like that
yeah I haven't had I learned from that
lesson and that will never happen again
what are the qualities now that you
would recognize in a guy like to say hey
I recognize those signs that's where you
stay away from what are some things you
learn from that
um
when I think about it
I feel like anything that feels like is
going in that direction I couldn't say
in one thing but
maybe maybe just not letting me allow me
to breathe
or not let me go because at one point I
wasn't able to leave
so maybe just like entrapment I would
see that earlier
would you classify them as high value
men
no probably the lowest you can find and
why why would you date the lowest
um why would I to be honest it was it
wasn't something I wanted to do
at all it was more the fact that I
actually just got into
a situation I couldn't see myself out of
and I was more insecure than like I
didn't know a lot of lessons so when I
got to that point
I had my own insecurities that later on
I had to learn that
you know through that experience not
that I needed that but through that
experience I learned that maybe
more about myself and how to be more
secure so after that situation it was
like I wouldn't be with someone like
that anymore you said you got siblings
right you got Brothers yeah one brother
older younger older and to see Mary does
he have a family no
okay
did you tell him about your abusive
boyfriend no I kept it to myself which
is really bad that you shouldn't do I
kept it to myself pray the worst thing
that I ever did
so why do like okay so from the first
hints of
I guess aggression how long did you stay
after like why did you stay because you
say I couldn't leave or it doesn't make
no sense to me
it goes back to insecurity
um
I think I was in Barry if I got into a
situation like that and I didn't know
how to get out of it and also I was I
didn't want my family to be involved and
I don't know why because they are like
the biggest provider of protection so it
was like in that situation I didn't know
how to come out of it and I didn't also
want it to blow up and I was scared for
some reason yeah right I'll say too like
I want to make sure your audience knows
it's like there's no this is not victim
blaming at all like the reality is there
are some very dangerous men I don't know
I get that but that's of course but the
thing about these really dangerous guys
and this is where women have to become
really really good at vetting guys
that's not probably the first or the
last time he's done that to a woman like
that like he did not escalate there by
accident that's going to be a repeating
pattern in that person's lives like what
is it like uh 10 or no five percent of
men basically commit like all the
violent crimes there are so these people
are like you know the player guys
they'll know how to recognize signs and
a woman how to pick her up how to sleep
with her etc etc there are there are men
they will recognize uh how to pick a
woman apart and escalate to that level
and in this case like you know we I
think we all just want to say we
definitely understand
um that like that's not normal and at
any point like there's nowhere in a
relationship should ever escalate that a
guy should lay his hand on a woman like
that is not okay but just being that
laying that very clearly yeah unless she
hits first
you still are not supposed to hit her
even if she hits first like I I that's
what I used to think until I saw some of
the hands that these girls were throwing
yeah but that's the guys yeah get the
hell out of there man why are you saving
that relationship that's a weak man and
it's like get out of that relationship
dude I'm with you but I think as a girl
you should be afraid if you hit a guy
you should expect to get hit back that's
my opinion you should at least consider
that there is a possibility that there
is a guy that would hit you back because
what I see with a lot of those videos is
these women they know he's not gonna
they they think they know that he's not
gonna hit back I I and I actually that's
why I brought this point I had this
friend and she was dating some guy and
it's the first time I'm meeting him at
some party right
and I could see it like right away from
the moment I saw her and I've known her
for a while I'm like hey you know how
are you I could see the way he was
looking at me and I'm like that guy is
probably beating her and I knew it
within two seconds and then later that
night there was a situation where I was
going up in the house to like some room
to pick up something and they were there
fighting and it was literally I walked
into the situation and I could see it
and then I pulled her assembly how long
has he been beating you she's like how
did you know my guys know guys can
recognize aggression very fast it's in
our DNA so that's why I think it's
important for you whenever there's
situations like that you need your
brothers you need the men in your life
to tell you what's going on because I
don't think women are as good at
recognizing these patterns before they
happen yeah you need guys we're talking
like the serious stuff we're not talking
like some made up [__] we're talking
about guys that actually beat their
women yeah this is where male relatives
are so important because a lot of times
a girl's guy friends are just trying to
bang her
you know so you need guys around you
like like a dad or brother those are
that's and that's always been the
traditional way right like it's always
been the brothers and the dad that
looked out for the welfare and this you
know of of the sister the daughter and
this is where like that relationship you
know
with the dad can be so important that's
why men have to step up and just and
like take responsibility and and be dads
like this is this is Paramount there'll
be another reason why I didn't know
because I didn't have that far figure to
show me that this is wrong and that's
right you think mentorship's important
having a mentor is having a role model
is important definitely see yesterday we
had Royal on here who was arguing you
don't need a role model you don't need a
mentor it's like we all do we all do I
think heroes are important too like
heroes in the media for people to look
up to like like because they'll always
[__] on like Andrew Tate and stuff but I
think like it's so great that young men
have like a masculine role model to look
up to and it's sad that as women we
don't have more like feminine role
models to look up to it's like cardi B
Beyonce like all these girls that say
they don't need men they don't care
about men equal feminine role models
aren't advertising aren't advertising on
social media I can't think of one
honestly I can't think of one feminine
like Jackie Kennedy's the only one I can
think of
I'd argue I'd argue that she'd be a good
feminine role model but that's a
different conversation no she wouldn't
be no she wasn't no that's a that's a
different conversation yeah it's about
her and I think it's the same as you
know very beautiful women don't complain
about guys yeah very beautiful very
feminine women they're picked off the
market rather quickly and then they live
their life and they just it's like you
buy a really good product you don't
really write a good review
um like like it's like yeah you don't
get you don't get like you know like the
last girl that was on here and you can
literally see her naked body on
Instagram I'm surprised that Instagram
account's not taken down that's clearly
violating but anyways
um you know and she's like projecting
that but like a married housewife type
of a lady that's raising kids and and
you know attending the garden driving
kids back and from school etc etc you
know that lady's not advertising like
she might you know she might have a
closed Instagram account with her
friends where they're sharing some stuff
but they're just not why would she
advertise it well that and and I would
say one more thing she has a negative a
negative incentive to advertising she
doesn't want to advertise her man to
other women not even that it's like most
of her friends are gonna [__] on her
yeah oh girl why are you dependent on
that guy no mostly most of her
girlfriends are exactly like her like
Pearl asked me two days ago if I know
anybody that's divorced like I'm 40.
I've been married for 10 years four kids
uh and I don't know a single divorced
person that I'm friends with like I
don't know anyone no which is crazy but
I'm talking more I'm talking more
younger women that might be looking for
a feminine role and a lot of them I
think want to be women but they're
afraid to go out and say it because
their single friends are gonna [__] on
them because the whole agenda with
feminism is oh you gotta have your
career you go baby bad [__] whatever
all this [__] so if you're very
feminine most of them are just like yeah
you know what I'm just gonna get my man
and he's treating me fine whatever I'm
not gonna like go out and try and change
the world can I ask and I don't think
yes and I with and you said like data is
out there yes because that's what guys
do that's male energy male energies
track if you want to change the world I
don't think women necessarily
feel that desire
can I ask you what do you have an idea
of like uh have you thought about what
an ideal relationship for you right now
or in the near future might look like
hmm
don't forget the question
um
I don't know if I've thought of it
maybe because
I've had some good experiences it's not
all bad but maybe with the bad
experiences it's like I feel like I've
had to learn
if I feel like if I find the right one
then what does it mean how do you know
what the right one is if you haven't
defined like Define the right one what
does that mean
that's the thing I don't know I don't
know yet
I can honestly say I don't know yet I
think it's just a feeling
for maybe if I feel security maybe
because I've I've lacked that in the
last relationship
and do you think do you think it's okay
to trust just your feelings and make
decisions just off your feelings
in the past now because I've learned
that that wasn't the right way do you
think the past might be a decent
predictor of the future
predicament well I mean like would if
you were to make decisions based on
improving yourself do you think using
the past experiences would be a good a
good way to learn on how to act in the
future or feel in future I think now
maybe from my experiences okay maybe
because I've been through some bad times
that I won't choose the same things okay
so you know what you don't want yeah but
what do you want
probably Safety and Security okay it's
the main thing yeah do you have an idea
of what that guy might look like what he
might be doing for a career what his
day-to-day routine might look like do
you have have you thought those things I
mean you must you must have some even
the most basic criteria
like can he be a Himalayan dwarf
[Music]
Transportation be donkey
let's start there looks at a bar there's
a homeless guy down the street that I
can say no thanks I don't want that
thank you so not homeless not a
Himalayan dwarf riding donkey
no maybe someone who is successful in
their own right or at least comfortable
um a confident strong man who can
provide and protect
are you dating these days
um not at the moment no
how many kids do you want
do I want and when would you like to
start having them you're 28 so you know
90 of your eggs are gone by 30 right
yeah so when you meet a guy tomorrow you
down
kids now no tomorrow
um
I've never thought of it I've never been
the type of woman that I wasn't the type
of child that either play with toys I
guess if I wasn't the type of girl that
played with dollies or thought of the
nuclear home
then maybe that's my problem but
I've never actually thought of it if I
for me because of my experiences if I
found the right guy
um and if they wanted to do that I would
want to do that for them so it's not
necessarily me wanting to have kids if I
found the security then I would
definitely want to have a child with
them
do you have any debt no no dad okay
um what was your last I know you
mentioned the abusive boyfriend what was
your the boyfriend before that what was
he like
before that
um
I feel like I never took anyone
seriously before that oh okay so you
didn't really it's interesting why why
do you think you took the bad boy
seriously
hmm
um
because I feel like
he came in shiny rapping
they come to you first as the perfect
guy they love bomb you and they show you
all the great things if only when you
get to a place where they think now I've
got you
then
they start doing certain things that you
don't agree with and then later on it
becomes
strange
and then I didn't really notice I was in
abusive relationship until six months in
wow so this is actually really
interesting we had a conversation uh
just like between uh between the little
sets here it's like men will definitely
project an image of themselves that's
not them and then women have to learn
and it's very dangerous for me right
it's like you're attracted to a guy but
he could literally like he could hurt
you it's like it's like there's a danger
involved that's the conundrum you know
that's the conflict women face on The
Dating Market
so you have to learn how to discern
between who's real and who's projecting
yeah and then it's the same thing for
guys right because men will project
status women will project Chastity like
women will project Purity and Chastity
and then what happens is women get like
wrecked in a series of shorter term
usually type of a relationships or as
rich as calls it you know Tyrone therapy
um I call it the gospel of Chad we have
a little whereas men will get wrecked
the other way right like a woman will
also project but then she'll get a
projection to get the guy to commit and
then insidiously ruin him in the long
term which is you're doing a documentary
on that where then a man gets dragged
into so it's like I can only speak from
a male perspective but I tell guys like
date women and learn about women by
experience so that you know what you're
dealing with you know women don't have
the privilege let's say of sleeping
around with a hundred guys so to figure
out like what is correct that's a
disadvantage women have because if they
do that their value is just like
completely decimated on the market guys
do have that opportunity you can you can
call it what you will but you need to
know you need to know before you commit
your life and half of your income
the paternity of your children and the
future access to your children that's
the mistake you risk making if you're
not good at evaluating women because you
don't have the experience to do that so
so you can get tricked by that shiny
rapping
I agree
you guys have more any more questions
actually it's a very important the thing
also those guys are really really good
at hiding that in the beginning but
those who can the person that they
cannot hide from is men that's why it's
really important when you're in a
relationship the most important thing is
introduce the guy that you're with him
if you're singing that that guy is going
for you it's gonna be serious introduce
him to someone to your parents to your
brother to your friends can't be a male
friend no I disagree with I can't be a
male friend you have to introduce them
to a man that's not trying to to bang
you she has a brother man yes
even if you don't think your brother
your brother's like even if you don't
think your brother is like that great
guy right now I don't know but like if
he's not the great guy right now women
will marry he'll still protect you yeah
as well like also his friends never fool
him in a relationship so I was not
believed even by his friends because
they didn't see him in that video his
friends will lie
he weren't even in a relationship before
his friend boys will protect boys girls
will protect girls they will they will
because I had that situation where his
friends were protecting him correct like
guys guys will cover for their friends
cheating women that you can't trust it
has to be somebody in your family that's
got like no chance of banging you
because they don't want to because
there's biologically for them negative
outcome to do that right yeah actually
it's very funny my mom I had two serious
religion relationships in my 20s one
five years and one two years and both of
them were great with my family and
everything but every time after I broke
up with them my mom came to me and said
I know that it's gonna end up one day
like shoot this girl wasn't for you and
I asked like why like how do you tell
that and she was like I could tell from
what I know you that you didn't match
like you were great to get their good
friends and everything but it wasn't
matching so and you say that in a few uh
podcasts to go also for a like you ask a
girl did you mom did your mom yeah
because girls will say I I um I had no
idea he just switched up but um I I
asked the question well did your parents
like them and they say no exactly so I
don't know did your did your mom meet
him not until six month failure did your
mom like him
I think they were just thin him out
so no no yeah yeah they were just seeing
him out they didn't really like get to
know him I mean honestly if that guy was
abusive
that to me sounds a lot like
Psychopathic behavior and there are
people like that I think it's about like
what three people and uh three percent
one percent of women yeah yeah and what
they do is very very interesting they
sugar coach in the beginning and they
make you feel amazing and then in their
presence you feel great then you feel
valued and validated and then they start
subtracting that yeah and controlling
you this way and then they Gaslight you
into thinking that's your fault yeah
which is kind of what you described
that's what I got from it that's typical
Psychopathic behavior and that's why
sometimes you know they're able to fool
people in the short term well keep in
mind that younger women tend to be
attracted to dark Tria traits yes yeah
well I mean if you have me as a brother
you would not be attracted to that
because I could see it right away yeah I
mean younger women seek out dark trial
like I mean how many um serial killers
have like Love Letters From women like
throwing themselves up um yeah
well one of the interesting biological
reasons that might be seeking out direct
behaviors is because risk seeking
behaviors in general are status seeking
behaviors these are like behaviors of uh
men that are like on their way up the
hero and the villain of the same traits
yes when you look at it so yeah no it
makes sense well the hero and the
villain are the same in fact yeah it's
just you know it's who wins it the end
gets to be the hero yeah yeah there's a
great book about that I gotta pull that
out again it's all about like Alexander
the Great anyways
um
um trying to think about their stuff you
want to ask you
what what do you see your life like 10
years from now
10 years from now
um
do you know what I don't know
like everything
I don't really know when I think about
it I think maybe like maybe kids
ownership
and the comfortable life
what can you offer the men you want that
is unique from other women unique
um
I think maybe
I don't know maybe I've learned a lot
from that but I know what
a man wants I can adapt to that and I
think that's what I offer more than
other women that I understand the man
and I can adapt to what they need okay
can can I have an example
um
if you want like a more feminine woman
or if you wouldn't I'm the type of woman
I'm independent on my own but I'm quite
feminine or submissive to a man when I'm
with a man through Maybe
if they want that then I can give them
that but also I can be
how
looking after the home whatever you want
I can adapt to it whatever you need
right yeah but I keep that okay imagine
I say like what are your skills for this
job and you're like whatever whatever
you need yeah like what what is the
like what so if I you know can I
introject look I can ask you you weren't
that abusive relationship when did it
end
um it ended uh as soon as I got
restrained although within last year
let's say no it was actually a few years
back back 2018. okay you're still pretty
shaken from that yeah like that I mean
the reason I'm introjecting Pro real
quick is like
um I just feel a little bit bad because
I mean that yeah that just messed up
your confidence in yourself that clearly
just you're you know we're trying to do
this thing where we're like we're asking
about like all these you know what makes
a wife etc etc but it's like I just feel
a little bit bad asking you know some of
these questions because it's like I can
just tell that like your self-confidence
was so shaken by that you know and I I
that makes sense it's like you know you
put yourself in that position and you
and then you just feel guilty you're
like how could I put myself in that
position how could I allow myself to be
in that position am I really like that
is that really who I am and so you kind
of start to get lost because you don't
have a compass of where you are and who
you are anymore because you lose who you
are yeah you know I mean I had to like
regain that and yeah it did change me
definitely because I did have social
anxiety of course I was like I couldn't
I had to adapt to talking to people
again I had to adapt to a lot of things
I had to catch up I feel like I um went
back in time with a lot of things or
just I wasn't who I was at one point so
I had to change but have you been to
therapy since no I have been thinking
about it though like I felt like I I do
self-heal a lot but there's only so much
you can do for yourself
yeah it might be good to see a
professional yeah a guy though not a
girl yeah
how come a guy
um because women look to Comfort men
look for Solutions
um I I think that most of the time women
there are exceptions in therapists but
I'm just in school for psychology and I
see the types of girls that are going to
become therapists and I promise you you
don't want it might also be good just to
spend time with a guy that's like
competent and a professional in that
environment right like just to give you
some guidance you say you know what
there are some guys out there that do
have my best interests in mind and and I
feel like a female psychologist here
might take the time to actually just
validate your feelings which is fine
versus like saying like hey there are
some behaviors in yourself you need to
correct as well in order not to not to
come to and I'm not a professional
psychologist I'm not going to get into
that but there is one piece of advice if
I could give as like just spend some
time on your computer and just write out
what you'd like your life to look like
in in three to three years five years
ten years just write it out yeah it'll
just force you to think like one of the
things that you know we talk about in
our business it's like it's so important
to have an ideal of what it is you're
striving towards it's like you know
because if we're just living off of our
our feelings all the time we become
hedonistic or we become masochistic like
it goes it can go outwards you know
we're just seeking pleasure or goes
inwards where you're just where you're
just punishing yourself
you need a North star like you need a
guidance you know for some people that
might be religion like they have the
church in our society we're pretty
secular we don't really have that
anymore you know and most people
listening to this aren't going to be
like that so it's like what's where
where you know you're you're in the
water and the waves are going different
directions the currents are pulling here
and there your boat is just floating
around it's like but where do you want
to be spend some time just sitting down
and we do this in business too it's like
you know right just write out what you
want what is it that you want and then
start looking at the world through that
frame you know this thing that I'm doing
is that getting me closer to what I want
or is that taking me further from what I
want
um I think you guys have any more
questions thank you for coming
um thank you for sharing that's yeah
thank you for telling us about it thank
you thanks
girl one which was
Dubai traveler oh the Dubai Channel yeah
Jesus Christ okay guys so what what did
you think of her
what did you think Pearl
you know
hey man I thought there was some green
I was like oh she oh she from here like
women aren't from like Western countries
they're a bit more traditional
um and I thought that she wasn't dressed
like super
[__] you know so I was like okay maybe
she's all right but then she started
talking
and um I had some concerns she seemed to
have a very like modern mindset
um what did you guys think
um I think yeah very similar first
impression that um she seemed like a
person who has everything very well put
together and then
she got triggered by some really basic
and easy questions which usually is not
a good sign so it's it shows that she
she was trying to hide something and
make herself look better
um in front of high value men yeah not
even that but it shows you how she's
gonna react in 10 situations which I've
never thought about that it shows you
that and that's one thing you can run as
a guy you can always run a little test
to where you do something that kind of
pisses her off
nothing crazy just a little something
and then you see the reaction and if the
person overreacts like crazy you don't
want to deal with this like how are you
going to deal with this when you're
married so this test it's not a test
actually to be like hey I'm going to do
something intentionally to annoy you
know it's the test of the direct
question about your behavior like
accountable people can answer for their
behavior accountably and easily like we
had a uh you know a situation we ask her
a question it's like you know this job
of yours it seems a little bit shady and
it's okay to ask like look if we ask
like you're flying to Dubai a lot and
you're it's like where are you getting
the money to fly to Dubai it's like well
you know this company how did you get
into this company oh my friend is a
flight attendant on a private jet and
she introduced me to the CEO and he he
hired me oh he just hired you and I said
can I ask you a question I'm like are
the other representatives in this
company they all happen to be beautiful
women and she goes chill out
right and I'm like okay she's I'm like
chill out for what I'm asking a
legitimate question it's a yes or no
answer if the answer is no it's no I'm
like okay you know let me back up is are
they or not she's like yeah they are why
does that why does that mean asking you
that question offend you like I can ask
you about your behavior right because
she's hiding something well look if
you're if you're a chick right and like
you have I've never been really offended
by a question I mean like right there's
some questions that are maybe a bit like
too personal that I'm like okay you know
right but but I'm like if someone asked
me okay because I let's play this game
right let's imagine let's imagine uh I'm
dating a girl right so and I'm thinking
for a serious relationship and I see
that there's a guy she's constantly
texting with oh so that's okay but am I
allowed to say hey how come you're
constantly texting with this guy and
then she goes chill out
what does that tell you about her should
you leave that's what it tells me right
so it's like why does she react that way
to a lot it's a logical like I'm
thinking like like I text blessing all
the time this guy asked me that I would
I would be like that's my producer
that's my producer here's the text it's
not like chill out it's like whoa yeah
it's like and then you get that and then
you kind of escalate that and you go
okay
and then she talks about her ex past
relationship and how her past
relationship was like toxic right it's
like interesting so you you day talks to
guys you're flying around to Dubai and
all these places with your private jet
company can I ask you a lot of guys on
the watching this it's like what kind of
experience do you think you can provide
to a girl that's been flying around in a
private jet to Dubai like are you gonna
wipe that check up and just expect her
to be like she's not gonna marry a
regular guy and give him a good time
she's experienced some stuff you know
right not even that man I mean I'm gonna
piss off a bunch of people
but I was if you look the way she looks
at 28 and you're single I'm suspect of
you right away right away because
beautiful girls
that are good people that have good
character are swept off the market super
quick so if you're very beautiful and
she was very good looking and you're 28
and you have zero zero prospects I'm not
talking like Rings or engagements I'm
talking you know you've been in a
relationship for three four years okay
cool and then you're dating now okay
cool but you have zero prospects I'm
suspect she also dated a famous guy
she tried to hide it but yeah I saw that
I saw all of that but that you can
literally see if you see a girl that's
like super beautiful and kind of nearer
to 30 you can bet she has all those
experiences and she's trying to
replicate her younger years in her older
years but guys wouldn't commit to her
not good guys well that's what I'm
saying our show just ruin somebody's
life it's like man you're dating I'm
like and I ask like you're famous guy
you're dating did you ever put a picture
with you no what did you see him a lot
no he was really busy with work so
sometimes look you weren't dating him no
you were you were the area code you know
right 304s I think you call them
that's from the calculator is that how
upside down
well there's an area called connotation
right yeah uh what about you what'd you
think of her
I mean I started I ended listen at the
beginning I was like nah this this is
not nothing yeah it's me like she was
always trying to
um
give a reason of her actions and try to
make it like look okay that we're not
judging okay we're not going and saying
like you're bad or good or something
like that but does Jimmy say when once
she started like getting all aggressive
and like responding back when you ask
her that's very yeah simple question
that's that's right to say that's the
reaction that you will get home when you
come back home and ask like is dinner
ready or where are my shoes or whatever
it's like you know imagine you have kids
with the trick and you guys disagree on
freaking uh clothing for the first day
of school and then she throws a tantrum
and she's like yeah yeah and you're like
you're freaking insecure because you
can't like handle my clothing choices
for the kids and you're like I don't
want to deal with that why would you as
a guy that has to work because I mean to
be successful you got to put in hours
and you got to put in hours consistently
and that takes energy and one thing that
is consistent with all successful guys
that they're very protective of their
energy so why would you spend your
energy trying to teach somebody to be
the basic basic characteristics of being
a woman why would you want to teach that
to somebody like you're a woman you're
supposed to be a woman I'm not going to
spend any time or effort teaching you
how to be one even if you can afford to
provide her the lifestyle that she's
already experienced flying around in
private jets to different places
would you still wipe her up no not at
all and I would I would not want to be
the guy kind of competing with guys that
have provided in the past I would want
to be the guy that gives her that first
yeah no definitely no that's that's
that's exactly right so
um usually you know we see these gals
you know she'll hit she's 30 in two
years and it's like then the prospects
that she's gonna have with these you
know dudes that are funding her
lifestyle which she didn't admit which
is clearly what's happening uh those
prospects are going to dissipate quite
rapidly
and then she's going to end up hitting
the wall and and go to the landfill of
the dating market and hopefully try to
find a nice guy that can't read through
those signals I think beautiful women
are almost at like even further
disadvantaged in dating because they hit
the wall later like a girl like that my
her looks might not go till 35 you know
be like just because she's so beautiful
but like but biology catches up to us
and like most girls don't know the
numbers when it comes to like getting
pregnant and that sort of thing yeah I
think if you're single and childless by
35 I think they know the numbers they
just don't want to believe it it looks
like in a lot of the shows they're like
um not not me yeah because I'm special
right right I'm Different what'd you
guys think of the second girl
so second girl would you say I said can
I have her number I'll get it I'll find
it that was there actually it's a really
uh I was talking to Demi before and the
guys it's like
at the beginning I couldn't believe what
she's saying was like I was like she's
in sales she knows how to probably play
the game and you know say what what you
want to to listen but then I don't
remember exactly what did she said but
everything turned it like turn it around
and I was like okay she's she's the real
deal like there is something here very
unique that you don't find everywhere
and it was
what'd you think I think we might differ
a little bit I liked her a lot as a
person and probably she would be
somebody I wouldn't mind hanging out
with you know if we happen to be in the
same room together
because she was fun well spoken from
Bulgaria which I'm from there so bonus
points for that uh and I don't want to
come off too hard that she seemed a
little too masculine she seemed to have
a little bit too much masculine traits
which which could be a thing of her
career right now with 22. it could be no
I think it's because she was raised by a
single mom and there has there has to be
a degree of that yes I I saw that so she
could be potentially wife material if
she realizes the importance of actually
being feminine but to me she seemed like
it would be a little bit of a struggle
competitive struggle for the dominance
in the relationship so it would require
a guy that is very very very very very
very very very masculine together to
commit to submit to him and I don't
think a lot of guys would want to deal
with the hassle of having to yeah but
don't forget she's only 22. that's what
I said that's what I started with so I
don't want to come off like too strong
and crazy to that point I think it's
good for like women to to hear it yes
yes so like at least we know a lot of a
lot of women when and we asked those
questions yesterday as well
um a lot of them when you ask them what
did the guys want they start describing
what they want and guys so it's like oh
you know he wants me to be ambitious he
wants me to be smart he wants me to make
my own money he wants me to and that's
like that to us is a huge turn off I
mean I wouldn't say it's necessarily
like a huge turn off you would still
smash if she was beautiful because weird
dudes it's like you know if you you
smash but it's like if you're looking
for a wife that's not attractive yeah
but she didn't say that when we asked
her that she cognizantly and quite
eloquently expressed that she
understands that uh you know in order to
fulfill the role of a wife she has to
act like the wife in that role and so
let me ask you a question because she's
22 and she's obviously pursuing
something at least at work related stuff
right the option is you have a girl with
her values or at least the value she
projects and we think she has but she's
folding sweaters in a retail store so
she's got no future prospects is that
better or worse I don't think it makes
any difference well there you go so then
why is it being a negative
say again then why is it a negative I
think the sweater folding makes any
difference I don't think I would value
this I will probably like the sweaters
more because there's less okay the less
times where she could have been like
flying here flying there I was on this
business meeting I met this guy I met
that guy because that's what I think
most guys hear when the the chick is
like busy like I'm doing this I'm going
there I'm doing that most guys even if
you're not doing anything
like promiscuous or whatever I don't
understand how this relates I don't
understand how this relates well you're
asking me if it makes a difference
no if she's folding sweaters she's
brought in 22 and that's her job she's
probably a little stupid
why no I don't think so really no I mean
compared to what she is I think she the
smarter version of hers doing this thing
she has to be cognitively better in
order to perform in a B2B sales role
like it doesn't mean that she's an
ambitious man but like obviously the if
she she that girl would not fold sweater
she'd be like this is stupid like why am
I folding sweaters she's like I'm better
than that
like a female dog what a female dog
could be a turn off I wanna yeah
yes I understand what you're saying I do
right
the thing is how smart do you really
want that's not the one that's not the
question the question is
um you're saying that like potentially
her being in the B2B sales room right
now 22 can be a turn off because she
would be competing with you right and
then when you asked her and you asked
her it's like you know would you blah
blah she's like no I would give up my
career like I would yes but what they
say and what they do is different and
that's 100 that's bringing it back to
what I said in the beginning is like
you'd have to like with her you would
date and you would kind of see how she
acts and situations you're not sure you
believe she was so submit
no I don't take anything at face value
for me because because I think a girl
with her values that's folding sweaters
would actually submit to an idiot
not necessarily I don't think she'd see
a bus driver is above her in status I
mean maybe like she'd have delusional
expectations I don't think they're so
logical about it to be honest fair I
don't I I honestly don't think they're
so logical I think that they're like oh
yeah I'm gonna have this job and then
you know you meet a guy and I I don't
think most guys really care what she
does for a job can I ask you did
anything about her like career right now
intimidate you at all no because you're
more successful
well you're obviously more successful no
no it makes no sense I'd like to hear
more like what did she what did she do
that sent you that like signal I just
want to hear more just the the just how
she was she was very confident she was
very you know handshake we we shook
hands and I'm saying I like the girl if
we were you know hanging out after you
know this I like her I'll talk to you
but I don't know if I would date you I
don't know if I if I have
how do sexual attraction to her oh okay
because she's just a little bit too
masculine that's Hungary it felt to me
because then I'm gonna be very honest
when you sleep with like professional
women it's like a freaking fight man
it's like a fight for dominance in the
bedroom it's like okay let's talk
professional how many partners do you
think she's had in her life
legit if I would say less than five
exactly so but you're sleeping with a
professional woman that's like 30. it's
a whole different story because you're
actually with the one with a lot of
masculine traits yeah that's that's but
but there but you know she was in a
long-term relationship from 16 to like
20. yeah four and a half years four and
a half years so it's like for her to to
have added another three to four guys in
the last two years do you think she's
the kind of girl that's added three to
four guys in the last two years
I mean you would have to see the friends
too yeah you'd have to you you would but
like you you didn't say she she got like
10 or 15 or 20 bodies that's not where
you went to like under five
yes based off of the conversation if she
I think if she's single at 28 your PO
your points are bang on
because then it's like yeah you're gonna
fight in the bedroom for dominance
because man like that's a different
person right but her body counts still
super low so it's like there's like
there's she's still I mean we never we
never know
we're trying to judge off of you know we
have the headphones and you cannot
really like lock ice with somebody and
really judge how they are and yeah fair
you don't have the physical touch to see
how they react because that's a very
easy way to tell right
um how to tell what uh how she's been if
she's been promiscuous or not but by
touching her physicality yeah like how
comfortable you are how early in the
date
oh okay I don't I totally don't agree
with that you don't I totally don't
agree that I I when I was single back in
like my early 20s me and my friend like
my friend met a girl uh took her home
hooked up with her first night like
within two hours and she and she was
like 24 beautiful and he was her first
yes I don't mean how fast you guys sleep
I mean when you touch on a date
I don't know how to like but it's it's
contextual I don't know
I've just never heard this so I just
wanted to so I don't know if I could
explain a date and she's like super
comfortable being actually I can explain
it I I was in a date with a girl in in
Thailand she wasn't from Thailand but we
met and we were talking and stuff and
you know you just send the hand to touch
her hand or something like that and she
uh she had a pass or she like freaked
out and she was like you know that
people are not that comfortable and
being touched and I think that this is
not that sometimes is like how
attractive she is to you but I think
okay so let's say you touch her and she
you can see she's like she's enjoying it
that she's a little how to say
embarrassed she's like oh well you know
he touched me and she's like kind of
bubbly and all that then you're like
okay like she's enjoying this she's a
little kind of not sure exactly how to
react if she's promiscuous the moment
you start touching she starts advancing
like fast but that means that she she
has an attraction to you yeah that's
that's yes that doesn't mean she's
attracted to every guy you're a very
high value guy a woman will treat you
that way
yeah that's what you should expect
because I've been on many dates and I've
been most of the time bang on on the
like how many guys they've had and all
that so so you can't be banging on with
her you think but you still sat under
five I would I would think that based
off of uh would you would you accept a
wife would you accept a woman as
potential for a wife if her body counts
for
yeah okay so so I just I think you know
you're because you're so you know you do
so well for yourself I think we're it's
like wow it's a professional woman a
white collar we're just like well
but like that's a young white call like
she hasn't got to that point yet where
her career superseded her hunt for her
husband she's not there yet man yes and
that's why I said that I would you would
date her and see but uh it's interesting
to actually hear the this this side
because I because some of them I
wouldn't even take out on a date some of
the girls you know that yeah you
wouldn't take them out on a date but
that's one thing that I kind of caught
on to just a little I don't know that's
why you date right that's why you go and
meet people and you have situations and
everything to see how they are really I
mean not automatically go and get
married but that's the kind of girl that
you will consider that on the on what we
had here today and plus I mean again
we're all different guys we of course
attracted to like this kind of same
characteristics but then also guys have
different you know one might like a tall
one the other might like a short one and
you know one might like this and that I
actually see that what the the example
that Demi gives with the girls as
folding sweaters I actually sees her
choice of a job as a
as a decision to put herself
in a valuable position in the market
because most of the chicken her age what
they do they go to work in bars they go
to work as waiters they go to work as a
flight attendant like those kind of
um
um jobs that you get attention from men
that you people are looking at you
people want to talk to she went to a job
that deals with hard work we all here
are in sales and we understand what is
that so when a 22 years old girl sitting
here and she's saying I'm selling she
said the B2B right b2g
that's [__] putting the effort and
consistent and I I can tell that from
also my experience in dating and the
relationship that I had that this is the
kind of girl the type of girl that I
will trust when something wrong will be
in their relationship to stay there next
to me and deal with it together and not
like
go like living or getting crazy or like
the one before that we just ask one
question and she got crazy she's also
not delusional she's not like I'm Gonna
Be A Millionaire with my
Etsy Crystal selling business I'm a
businesswoman she wasn't delusional she
was actually following a fairly
consistent path towards something yeah
so so I mean again I can't see that as a
super negative I understand what you're
saying like you know she's pursuing a
career but like a female doctor
I've known several like they can still
be very
feminine and very accommodating at home
because you know just like there's that
aspect of them that's like the Healer
role what did you think
um
yeah I I yeah all she left a very good
impression in terms of the way she was
um talking and and the way her mindset
was so
for for me not a cat lady okay so what
do you guys say cat lady or not cat lady
I don't think she's gonna be a cat lady
okay you think she'll be a wife yeah
okay
girl number three
which one was that that was uh the one
with the Instagram well I mean like like
God you know man like
I mean how many like I mean I think I
was telling that the river before
someone coming to to work with us and
they will say I want to be a millionaire
but I actually we have that example but
I'm I I don't like to make calls
I mean she was saying this is what I
wanted this is what I want but I don't
want to do what I need to do for I I
enjoy doing what I'm doing I'm enjoying
playing the victim and giving excuses of
the thing that I'm getting today
and we were all like I think the
conversation became very fast to some
let's say a life advice conversation
instead of asking her questions and she
was like she saying I'm listening but
she wasn't listening she was like trying
to give an excuse and and justify I
think she was hunting for a man yeah
how to get it because she was like I
think you should get it if you would
naked pictures there right dude and then
and then she started I think the first
thing she when she was sitting down was
like ah the the guys I date it's just
only losers and it's like oh maybe
they're a little bit related and she
couldn't put it together that it's
actually she's like she's like you know
you're showing your tits on Instagram
like the moment I see it I'm like okay
you're not like 3 000 guys have liked
your tits and you can just see them this
was like how is this how's this how's
Instagram not obfuscating those photos
like it's just there okay fine be your
best self-love your movie but it's like
and when you say hey maybe you shouldn't
put your tits on Instagram she's like
well they're even better in real life
what are you selling yeah yeah then they
should come save her she don't want to
be saved
if God didn't save her who are you to
save her um okay what do you guys think
cat lady or why like if she continues
like that definitely a cat lady if she
changes a few things which is nothing
she's not stupid she's not like she she
has something if she put herself yeah
but you can be smart and delusional yeah
of course well that's why I was I was
telling her I was like
you could just delete the Instagram make
a new one people probably won't find it
if you put it under a different username
it's like you could maybe walk away from
this and come out okay you're pretty
enough
I don't think she she like here's a
question why do women put sexually
promiscuous photos up on public networks
and advertise themselves you know why
because they're marketing yeah and if
she continues to Market it means she
likes what the marketing is bringing in
you know there's just like a uh it's
she's not she's like oh I mean some of
these guys are losers like she like it's
every Chad and Tyrone with the six-pack
is hitting her up with a shirtless photo
and she's like hell yeah I mean it's
also a very easy way to make wealthy but
maybe a little delusional guys as well
spend money on you just tell him oh yeah
my previous boyfriends he was a loser he
couldn't get me like anything and then
obviously if you're wealthy and you're
thirsty
what is your first thought oh I'm gonna
get her all this stuff and and maybe you
know she would like me she gave a lot of
signals here that's exactly what she
wanted yes I mean it's very easy to tell
man when you look at this Instagram it's
like
yeah you know if you have zero options
or if you're just horny and you want to
cheat on your wife you would message and
you're like yeah let me take you out but
if you're a guy that has options for sex
you would you wouldn't take her on a
serious date like why you know you know
what you're gonna get if you've been on
enough dates you know exactly what
you're gonna get I mean I could probably
have the same conversation with her with
just myself
you know you know exactly what the
conversation is going to be like how's
it going to go how are you guys going
it's boring just takes energy it makes
no sense
girl number four
I think we all feel a little bit bad man
you know it's like we get into this
situation you start asking questions and
because there was some you know I mean
there's some sure she would probably
have been a different person four years
ago and probably she would have fit more
into that delusional category that we
saw with girl number three but she
actually found out like the the negative
the very severely negative outcome of
like not properly vetting the men that
she let access to you because that's the
danger of not vetting men like if you're
attracted to men with dark Tria traits
which these you know young narcissistic
ladies definitely are then that's the
risk you run as you run into a real
narcissist or a real psychopath and then
you get entrapped into an abusive
relationship and you come out with your
confidence completely destroyed and I
think when it's like obviously like if
you're a healthy man you're not gonna go
and try to rescue a woman right like the
White Knight thing that's just like
losers are trying to be the White Knight
like that's it's not a man's role to to
bring out the angel and a woman really
if you want to look at how traditional
marriages worked it's been
but traditional relationships have
worked it's been a woman who has taken
on the role of bringing out the angels
and the man you know it's like he's
taming his he his danger and then
because he's taming his danger she comes
in and supports him and he grows more in
this case it's like if you're taming her
danger and that's a real danger that
you're dealing with like you're gonna
deal with some trauma in that there's
going to be a lot of fallback
trust issues
um probably some some very negative
reactions to some very regular
circumstances that remind her of what
happened in the past it's like you can't
you can't consider that for a wife and
that's mean to say because you know at
some level you also have to say like
well she was a victim like she was a
legitimate victim in that sense too
um that's that's an unfortunately
negative outcome I just I hope she hope
she goes to therapy yeah yeah it looks
like for her yeah she she didn't really
know what she's she wants what is she
looking for what is a good character in
a man anyway so I think she needs to
figure that out for herself to to have a
great future I mean I think when you
when you actually called out the truth
which was hey you know obviously you're
still emotionally
um
it's more traumatized traumatized right
she kind of LED loose a little bit she
kind of loosened up a little bit then I
think if if somebody a professional
spends some time with her she might
actually know exactly what she wants she
might be able to verbalize it but I
think if you've been abused you kind of
learn to be small and not have any
opinion on anything that's what that's a
lot of what I was seeing just one word
answer super quick Snappy no eye contact
then
man I mean I I wish her the best I
really do and I'm sorry that they're
freaking you know
Psychopaths out there you know so listen
to men you know find Good Men your
brother your dad and kind of bring men
to them and have them
save yourself I think she shows that the
effects of a single parent or a single
mother home it's like it doesn't just
affect you it affects your kids it
affects your like the guy it affects
everyone around you and there's you know
catastrophic effects in society so I
think one one important thing is don't
like all the ladies out there if you're
getting into a situation like this don't
be afraid to go in and talk about it I
mean not to one person because most of
the people go and talk and then they
receive it not the the real no the
answer that they were expected not the
response that they were expected so if
you feel that something is wrong and
it's not supposed to be like that don't
stop sharing until you find someone that
is with you and
and don't don't leave it to be too far
away I mean I'm talking from a personal
experience
and from my sister she she has like a
relationship that her boyfriend
committed suicide and I was talking with
her through all that time and she told
me later that she was scared of telling
me because he asked her not to say like
all the issues that he was dealing with
because he was afraid and today I make
sure that I'm talking with my sister on
everything and asking her about every
guy that she's dating how is she and
everything because
we sit here I can affect someone
someone's life later and don't feel the
secure that you can feel from from a guy
and it's maybe she's a she's a good
woman we don't know but we will never
know if she doesn't talk about it right
the good man would create for his woman
and environment in which she can be
fully feminine and have no worries
that's a way you can tell if that's a
good man or not
well thank you guys all for coming um
it's really interesting to hear like
what guys think about when they're
dating because as a girl you just don't
always hear this so I really appreciate
you guys coming
um where can the people find use or any
social media you want to plug
lgfg fashion house that's the only thing
that you need to yeah guys it's like you
know look
um the thing the thing about being a
dude it's a little different it's like
um when you're a woman and you're a four
or five or whatever your your number of
attractiveness in the market value
however you quantify that is like guys
are still going to be approaching you
guys are still going to be giving you
attention guys are going to be kind of
pursuing you and you kind of you kind of
feel like you know you have it pretty
easy at least some guys pursuing you're
getting a ring getting a relationship's
a different thing but when you're a man
and you're like a four or five you're
basically getting zero that's just how
it works like if you're if you're a man
you got to be a seven and up and there's
a lot of different ways to accomplish
that you know lgfg fashion house that's
lgbg.com uh that's what we are in the
business of we're in the business of
recruiting young men women too uh but
but let's say recruiting young men into
sales where they can learn how to build
their wealth how to build their mindset
of abundance how to build their
discipline how to build their integrity
and accountability through the science
and art of sales dealing with with high
net worth professionals because that's
whom we sell custom suits to so clients
like Jordan Peterson clients like uh
Frank Mir now from the UFC Lenox Lewis
Alice Cooper the rock star etc etc
that's the kind of people that we work
with so if you're looking for a career I
don't care if you have a University
degree or not uh if you're a hustler if
you're hard working and if you want to
get your value up from a six to a seven
from a seven to a nine whatever that is
lgfg.com uh we are hiring and we are
mentoring young men to win
oh thank you guys for coming
um guys like the video on your way out
um and let me know are there any
influencers in London that you'd like to
see come on on the next episode of why
for cat lady
um I think this is a fun series because
you know do this again like the video on
your way out guys subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell
we'll talk to you next time